So, jetzt ziehen wir hier mal ein bisschen die Musik raus, weil das stört ja alles nur.
Die Musik stört da nicht.
Und eröffnen hier das Ganze mal mit ein bisschen Klambumm. Na, da weiß man wenigstens, da weiß man wenigstens, dass es losgeht.
Vor welcher Serie war das?
Was, wie wo? Ja, das ist der selbe wie das letzte Mal. Ich hab mir bis jetzt noch nichts besseres eingefallen. Ich hatte bisher noch keine Zeit.
Ist doch von irgendeiner Serie geklaut? Hotel oder Las Vegas?
Ich hab plötzlich das erste Mal das Channel 4 News Team gehört. Kennt ihr das?
Anyway, hier ist Mobile Max Ausgabe Nummer 42. Bam, ba, bam, bam, ba, ba, da. Was auch immer das bedeuten mag, keine Ahnung. Aber ein runder Geburtstag ist es nicht. Aber es soll ja Leute geben, die sich von dieser Zahl inspiriert fühlen. Gehör ich eigentlich auch dazu? Das ist immer super im Audio-Podcast, irgendwelche Bilder auf dem Laptop hochzuzeigen. Jetzt musst du auch so ein bisschen dieses ich beschreibe, was ich sehe-Spielchen spielen.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Film von, das ist drei, vier Jahre alt, das Spiel geht, das ist so eine 70er-Jahre-Lokal-Fernsehsender, News Team Crew, die immer über die neuesten Auto-Unfälle und Panda-Geburten berichten. Und die werden in ihrer Sendung mit dem ultimativen Problem gestellt, nämlich, dass sie ein neues Teammitglied bekommen und das eine Frau. Das kommt ihnen natürlich überhaupt nicht mit klar.
Weil das alles solche Schnauzbärte sind, die so eine Klickkette da drin haben.
Der eine hier, der ist zu doof gerade zu stehen und das hier ist halt der Sportmensch, der so aussieht wie so ein Texas Cowboy und so. Und es sind halt alles totale Machos natürlich.
Du meinst, wir müssen uns jetzt auch alle solche Oberschenkelbürsten wachsen lassen und Cowboy-Tüte tragen?
Der Jingle passt dazu.
Ah so, der Jingle ist eigentlich kein Jingle. Das ist mehr so ein Wachmacher, damit wir alle auch wissen, dass jetzt die Sendung wirklich losgeht. Stimmt's? So sieht's aus. Wir haben ja viel Zeit verstreichen lassen. Das liegt daran, dass wir generell derzeit einfach ein Termin Koordinationsproblem haben.
Wir haben ja nur eine Woche ausgelassen, oder?
Ja, gut, aber…
Ja, drei Scherz zwei ist schon ziemlich hart, aber…
Ausgelassen ist ausgelassen, ne?
Ja, ich komm ne halbe Stunde zu spät, du ne ganze Woche.
Lass mir das…
So, wollen wir dieses Thema mal wieder schön in den Podcast einbauen?
Die schmutzige Wäsche wird dann später gewaschen. Ja, ansonsten haben wir wieder viele interessante Hinweise bekommen in der Public Wave, die wir, das hab ich gleich vorweg, nicht alle bearbeiten können. Das macht jetzt auch wenig Sinn, während der Sendung da noch groß was einzutragen. Denn das werden wir jetzt eh nicht mehr tracken können. Wir haben uns sozusagen ein Destillat daraus gebildet und uns die Themen rausgesucht, wo wir überhaupt was sagen können, uns nicht vollständig blamieren und wir uns zutrauen. Nein, heute blamieren wir uns nicht vollständig. Ich war auch so viel mit anderen Podcasts beschäftigt, muss ich zugeben, in den letzten Tagen und Wochen. Ich hab fast nur CRI gemacht die ganze Zeit. Aufgenommen oder geschnitten? Ich bin fleißig, es gibt richtig ordentlich Material. In den nächsten zwei Monaten ist auf jeden Fall kräftig Dampf angesagt. Uns wird ganz toll. Aber es ist ja jetzt hier nicht der Ort, um Groß-Eigenwerbung zu machen. Wir wollen unsere zweifelhafte Rolle als Apple-Fanboys wieder öffentlich ausleben. Ich wurde ja interviewt von Philipp bei DCTP. Dann wurde ich auch schon von der Seite gefragt. Philipp Banzer, der Küchenradio auch macht, Mininradio und er hat alle möglichen Interviews, Blogger, Podcaster und so. Philipp war auch dabei übrigens und so die üblichen Verdächtigen. Dann kam dann auch wieder so von der Seite, wie ist denn das überhaupt und warum machst du denn das? Und ihr seid ja alle so Fanboys und so. Ist das denn überhaupt so in deiner Ehre?
Kannst du das überhaupt von dir?
Was sagst du später dem Schöpfer, wenn du irgendwie vor ihn trittst und du hast irgendwie über Apple gearbeitet?
Genau, das ist super, das muss ich bemerken.
Tja, was soll ich sagen, ich bereue nichts hier. Wir wollen auch weiterhin das Apple-Universum auseinandernehmen. Das macht nämlich Spaß.
Ich bin gefragt worden, ob ich mir denn ein iPad, ob ich das dann toll finde und ob ich mir eins kaufen werde. Ich hab gesagt, ja, ich glaub schon. Ja, ich dachte schon, weil du jetzt ja so ein Android-Fanboy bist, weil du ja ein positives Android-Fanboy bist. Ich hab gesagt, dass das nicht total scheiße ist und dass das ein gutes OS ist. Das heißt jetzt wieder. Ja, du bist der Brandmarkt. Und ich werd auch diesmal wieder positives über Android sagen.
Man ist so schnell in einer Ecke, das ist wirklich echt einfach.
Darf ich nicht ZFS-Fanboy?
Ja, du bist der ZFS-Haini. Huckel ist schon so dieser Programmier-Nerd irgendwie.
Ausgerechnet Huckel. Das ist schon echt lustig.
Der könnte mithören.
So im Delirium?
Aber später.
Der kennt die URL nicht. Das ist lustig, aber Huckel ist mal so als der Gestaltertyp im Club aufgeschlagen.
Ich kann irgendwie nur Grafik. Und mit diesem Programmieren hab ich nichts drauf.
So ein Photoshop-Typ.
Ich hab ja mal irgendwann seinen Blog gesehen. Der ist ja noch der klassische Grafiker.
Der ist halt einfach durch die harte Schule des CCCB gegangen. Da hat er halt keinen Stein auf dem anderen.
Der macht ja auf FreeBSD Installationen. Jetzt macht er gerade Hardware-Buzzle-Line mit Admin uns und bringt LED-Türme zum Leuchten. Also so 3D, so wie was Stein jemand groß hatte. So ein LED-3D-Würfel. Macht jetzt einen kleinen mit LEDs und legt richtig los mit Löten und Machen und Tunen und volles Programm.
Vielleicht noch ein letztes Wort zu dieser Wave. Also ich wär ja immer noch ganz glücklich, wenn es dafür immer so eine Outline-Funktion gäbe. Ich hoffe, dass irgendjemand schon mal so eine Extension gebaut hat. Ich hab allerdings dieses Wave-Universum wenig verfolgt in letzter Zeit.
Wie ist eigentlich das Wave-Resümee? Also ich mein, das gibt's jetzt nur, weil ihr benutzt es anscheinend ich ja nicht so, weil irgendwie ich muss auch immer ein bisschen abschalten vor allen neuen Sachen. Ich muss erstmal nicht immer sonst zu viel.
Google hat, da werden wir ja wahrscheinlich eh noch zu kommen oder vielleicht machen wir das dann auch gleich zum ersten Thema, Google hat irgendwie das Problem, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, ausreichend zu kommunizieren, wofür ihre Tools jetzt eigentlich wirklich taugen. Und so dieser Weg mit, na ja, Google Wave wäre ein E-Mail... Naja, genau. Also was auch immer der Grund ist. Auf jeden Fall liegen sie irgendwie nicht richtig. Also dieses Wave gegen E-Mail zu positionieren war so im Rückblick erstmal ein strategischer Fehler, weil man sich natürlich dann auch sofort alle Vergleiche anhören muss und dafür taugt es halt nicht. Es gibt halt immer wieder so Sachen, die tauchen so auf und es hat schon so ein bisschen was von Spam manchmal. Weil einfach Leute irgendwelche Waves da einem in die Inbox hinein propagieren. Klar, mir könnte jetzt auch jeder eine Mail schicken, aber es ist irgendwie so eine gewisse Nachlässigkeit danach. Man wird halt einfach hinzugefügt und dann taucht das bei einem auf und die Leute machen sich da nicht groß Gedanken. Wenn ich eine Mail an jemand schreibe, dann ist da irgendwie eine ganz andere Hürde dabei. Und die findet so bei Wave die Karte.
Die kann ich löschen, denn bei Wave entwickelt sich das Ganze erst. Selbst wenn ich sage, ich werde jetzt zu einer Wave...
Also manchmal sind so statische Sachen, wo man weiß, das war jetzt die Mail, die bleibt so und ich hab die jetzt abgelegt. Die ändert sich auch nicht mehr. Das ist eigentlich manchmal eine gute Sache, oder?
Die nervt vor allen Dingen nie wieder. Während so eine Wave poppt dann immer wieder auf.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen doof. Aber ich finde, dass es für unsere Zwecke hier eigentlich ganz gut ist. Also es funktioniert definitiv besser als Wikis. Das muss man schon sagen. Dadurch, dass es so Visivic out of the box ist und der Zugang ist schnell gemacht und es dann irgendwie auch klar, wer hat wie wo was gemacht. Das ist schon okay. Und ich denke, das ist auch der Weg, den sie weitergehen müssen. Also einfach collaborative working. Aber dafür, finde ich, stört dann eben manchmal auch diese Threat-Geschichte. Und da haben wir ja auch schon drüber geredet. Und dieses Replies mittendrin. Das ist einfach zu viel. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen bei Google wahrscheinlich auch gerade so eine kleine Nerd-Krankheit, die da ausbricht, dass sie eigentlich zu viel bringen. Und dass sie so ihre Mega-Eleganz, die sie so bei ihrem Such-Interface immer wieder gezeigt haben und was sie auch glücklicherweise auch beibehalten, nicht so diese nackte Suchseite, die sie auch noch durch diese netten JavaScript-Gimmicks da unterstrichen haben. Kennst du diesen Effekt, dass du diese Google-Seite aufmachst und du siehst wirklich nur...
Und sie sieht aus wie die original Google-Seite?
Sie sieht aus wie die original... Ne, was ich meine ist, dass diese ganzen anderen Sachen, die da noch sind, was du sonst noch so an Menüs machen kannst, ausgeblendet wird.
Ja, genau, das meinte ich ja mit. Sieht aus wie die Google-Seite damals.
Aber das sind so Feinheiten, wo man auch immer wieder merkt, wie gut sie das verstanden haben. Bei diesen Diensten vermisse ich es dann so ein bisschen. Das ist... Ich finde nicht alles scheiße, aber es ist ein bisschen überladen und es führt dazu, dass zu viele Leute das auf zu viele unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen benutzen und es sich dann einfach kein herrschendes Benutzungsmemo herausbildet.
Ich finde es ja bei Wavefin ist ja noch alles erträglich, wo es wirklich nervt, das bei Buzz finde ich.
Ja, da können wir ja mal... Da sollten wir jetzt mal drüber reden.
Ja, dann können wir das nämlich mal...
Bootsie, Bootsie, Bootsie Maus kam irgendwie... Wann war das?
Also total Google-untypisch.
Erklär doch mal, was deiner Meinung nach Buzz ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was Buzz ist. Ich sag einfach mal, was passiert ist. Google macht eine Pressekonferenz oder eine Keynote oder was auch immer und stellt vor, dass sie jetzt Buzz haben. Und dass innerhalb von 24 Stunden jeder, ob er will oder nicht, in seiner Gmail-Inbox einen Buzz-Button plötzlich hat und so und so viele Freunde hinzugefügt hat. Und das ganz automatisch und seitdem nervt da ein Dienst rum, der irgendwie so ein bisschen an Twitter erinnert und ein bisschen an FriendFeed und ein bisschen, wohl sehr an FriendFeed, also ich hab FriendFeed nie genutzt, ein bisschen an diese Facebook-Notification-Funktion. Und seitdem ist der da, dieser Buzz-Button und nervt einfach. Und man sammelt jetzt Follower und ich will es eigentlich gar nicht so richtig.
Und dass er sein FriendFeed erinnert, liegt wahrscheinlich da dran, dass Google FriendFeed auch gekauft hat und ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass das FriendFeed-Team auch dann dieses Buzz-Team im Wesentlichen ausmachen dürfte.
Auf jeden Fall ist es...
Na sie versuchen, ich meine, das ist ja erstmal ein heeres Ziel, also eine Melange zu erzeugen aus den Vorteilen von Twitter, also das Follower-Modell. Dann finde ich diese Diskussion, die sich daraus abzeichnet, erinnere mich eher so an diese Facebook-Status-Geschichten, wo du halt auch Replies etwas expliziter siehst. Also es bildet einfach mehr ab, worauf sich jemand bezieht, während es zwar diese Abbildung theoretisch in Twitter auch gibt, aber üblicherweise so in den User-Interfaces gar nicht so herausgestellt wird, es sei denn du klickst dann mal eine Konversation in deinem Twitter-Client an und dann siehst du das, aber es ist nicht so, dass schon das Default-Interface dir so ein Konversations-Thread geben würde. Und was meinst du, warum das mit Friend-Feed zusammenhängt?
Ich hab Friend-Feed nie genutzt, ich hab nur von Leuten, die Friend-Feed kennen gesagt, dass sie ja Friend-Feed haben. Ich hatte da irgendwann auch mal einen Account und fand das immer eher so, ja.
Ja, ich hab auch so einen Friend-Feed-Account. Ich benutze Friend-Feed nicht. Ich biete nur auf Friend-Feed an und staune mal wieder, dass das auch Leute benutzen.
Also was ich bei Bass wirklich furchtbar finde, ist extrem unübersichtlich. Es ist egal, zu welchem Zeitpunkt ich hier Bass einschalte. Ich hab immer irgendwas von Sascha Lobo oder von Cosma vorne. Und zwar nicht, weil die so viel schreiben, sondern weil jedes Mal, wenn die einen Kommentar kriegen auf ihren Bass, der Nachricht plötzlich wieder ganz nach oben poppt. Nun interessiert mich nicht die Bohne, was der 120. Follower von Sascha Lobo zu diesem möglicherweise ganz originellen Ursprungsbass mal gesagt hat. So, ja, finde ich genau. Super. Das nervt einfach. Das mag so eine Diskussionskultur, dass man dann ein bisschen kommunizieren kann und so was. Dafür mag das ganz praktisch sein. Aber dadurch ist es automatisch immer so eine Hierarchie. Und die Sachen von kleineren Leuten, die nicht so viele Follower haben, die kriege ich tatsächlich nicht zu Gesicht, weil ich mache mir nicht die Arbeit, da jedes Mal komplett runter zu scrollen, zu gucken, hatte ich das jetzt schon, hatte ich das noch nicht. Und das nervt einfach. Das ist bei Twitter viel besser. Da ist jede Nachricht gleichberechtigt. Und hier, die poppen nach oben, die fallen wieder runter. Und dann diese Verknüpfung mit den Google-Kontakten, finde ich auch gar nicht gut.
Ja, ich meine, das ist nämlich das Ding. Sie haben ja Buzz in Gmail eingebaut.
Nein, nicht nur in Gmail.
Wie meinst du das?
Das ist zum Beispiel auch im Google-Reader drin, auf so einer Art.
Ach so, okay, gut, dann sagen wir mal, sie haben es in ihre Google-Apps eingebaut. Kann man das so festhalten? Aber es ist halt auch Teil von deinem Gmail. Was ich vermute, was ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, durch Tests so jetzt noch nicht überprüft habe, ob diese Vermutung überhaupt zutrifft, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass sie da eigentlich ein Intranet-Tool bauen. Dass das sozusagen etwas sein kann, was so bei Work Groups ganz gut ist. Weil natürlich interessiert dich nicht der 30.000.000. follower, der den 120. Kommentar zu einem Bass von Sascha Lobo sagt. Aber angenommen, wir würden jetzt für diesen Podcast, wir drei sozusagen unsere Diskussionen über diesen Podcast in Bass führen. Auch im Kontext unseres E-Mail-Accounts. Das hätte sozusagen die Idee, dass da ein Werkzeug entsteht, mit dem man besser kommunizieren kann. Dann könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass man eben genau das will. Wenn ich auf den Kommentar von Dennis antworte in einem Bass, dass der dann bei dir nach oben rückt. Weil der dann nämlich für dich auf einmal relevant ist.
Ja, also es kann durchaus, für solche Menschenmassen, wie man sie bei Twitter hat, funktioniert es auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. Auch die Follower-Größen. Es könnte vielleicht in so einem kleineren, familiären Umfeld oder ähnlichen, könnte es ganz gut funktionieren. Kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Das heißt, das eigentliche Problem von Bass ist, dass es öffentlich ist. Und da sind sie ja auch ganz kräftig erstmal in den Stacheldrahtzaun gelaufen, mit diesen automatischen Listen von den Leuten, mit denen du am meisten kommunizierst, zu bilden und die dann automatisch zu Followern zu machen und das dann auch noch public zu machen. Also hurra! Also ein paar Wochen vorher haben sie irgendwie noch China angespuckt, so nach dem Motto, ihr wollt hier unsere Dissidenten, die wir irgendwie für euch verstecken, ausspionieren und danach...
Und jetzt wird automatisch eine Liste mit den Leuten, die mich nicht komplizieren, ins Netz gestellt.
Und hier sind übrigens alle ihre Freunde, die sie verhaften, als ganz großes Kino.
Da muss wirklich ganz schwer was falsch gelaufen sein. Und ich ermesse gar nicht, was da der Grund für sein kann. Weil, wenn sie auf der einen Seite jetzt dieses wir sind dann doch Privatsphäre liebend, als PR-Meme wiederentdeckt haben, andererseits ihnen aber solche Sachen unterlaufen, dann kommt man ja schon langsam ins Grübeln, ob nicht Google so langsam Microsoft-Verbürokratisierung in Ordnung macht.
Genau, nicht nur in deren Sicht. Google ist so ein... Ich hatte auch diesen Gedanken, dass Google jetzt das neue Microsoft ist und das ist jetzt die Manifestation davon. Und zwar nicht mehr dieses, wir haben eine Idee, und die ist geil, und die setzen wir jetzt um und die lassen wir dann erst mal schön am Markt reifen, sondern zum einen sind es ja vom Marketing her total anders vorgegangen, nämlich dieses BAP, du kriegst das jetzt einfach. Wir nehmen die User-Basis, die wir haben, und zwingen denen das einfach auf, und die werden es schon nutzen, egal wie gut oder schlecht das ist. Weil wir drücken es ihnen rein. Das ist das eine. Das zweite ist so dieses wir müssen alle unsere Dienste integrieren, wir müssen Reader und Mail und das und das zusammenführen und nebenbei müssen wir noch probieren, drei, vier Konkurrenten, die es vor uns besser gemacht haben, in den Arsch zu wicken. Also auf jeden Fall.
Haben wir Glück, dass wir nicht im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sind.
Ja, das wäre jetzt...
Wenn jetzt tot, würde jetzt der Sendungsleiter reinkommen mit dem hochroten Kopf und sagen, Leute geht's noch?
Ja, aber das ist...
Schaltet die ab! Das ist live, das ist im Internet. Das ist jetzt ewig gespeichert. Es hat schon das dritte Backup hinter sich. Dein Kommentar ist jetzt schon auf der vierten Festplatte.
Fünf, sechs. Das kriegen wir nie wieder raus.
Du hast das Internet voll mit Ficken vollgemalt. Lass uns ein neues Internet bauen.
Ich finde Google Buzz ziemlich misslungen auf diversen Ebenen.
Okay, aber siehst du vielleicht noch irgendeine Möglichkeit, das zu irgendwas sinnvollen zu benutzen?
Das ist doch ein Nerven.
Mir fällt es jetzt schwer, darüber zu ranten. Als das hochkam, war ich gerade auf einer Tagung und dann habe ich im iPhone zur Kenntnis genommen, dass sie auch so ein Mobile-Interface haben. Nach einem Zehnmal klicken hatte ich das Gefühl, es gibt drei verschiedene Arten und Weisen, wie man dieses Bass visualisieren kann. Es gab mal so ein Menü und mal so ein Menü. Was auch noch interessant ist, dass sie auch noch diese Geo-Geschichte mit reinbauen. Sie gehen ganz viel an. Es ist ein bisschen Friend-Feed, es ist ein bisschen Facebook-Status, es ist ein bisschen Twitter, es ist ein bisschen Mail, es ist ein bisschen Foursquare und Grovala, also so Location. Weil ich hab dann so gedacht, hier.
Ein bisschen alles, aber nichts richtig.
Das ist natürlich immer die Gefahr bei solchen Sachen.
Das kannst du nicht passen nennen sollen, sondern Frankenstein. Davon gehen wir was ein Teil und davon gehen wir noch was Totes und da noch einen abgeschnittenen Fußnagel.
Oh, Google-Komunculus. Also ich sag nicht, dass das nicht möglich wäre aus so einer Konstellation. Also wenn es einem gelingt, die Essenz aus allem zu nehmen und dann auch wirklich, nicht wahr, keine Frankensteine, sondern alles im Wunderland zu bauen, dann ist ja alles gut. Das ist natürlich sehr schwierig. Das probieren sie ja auch alle.
Was mich jetzt noch sehr nervt daran, das ist, dass es meine bestehenden Google-Dienste, die ich sehr gerne nutze und die ich vielleicht nicht integriert gerne nutze und auch nicht dringend kommunizieren will, dass es mir die ein Stück weit kaputt macht.
Service pollution.
Also, irgendjemand hat das gesagt, am Anfang habe ich es nicht verstanden, aber ich konnte das dann innerhalb von zwei Tagen sehr gut nachvollziehen. Er meinte, so seine Gmail-Inbox, das war vorher so der heilige Raum, in dem man quasi nicht, der nicht Echtzeitkommunikation oder ähnliches. Also da mache ich nicht nur öffentliche Sachen. Plötzlich ist da so ein Ding drin, da war alles, was ich da reinpappe, öffentlich. Und bei mir ist es sehr stark aufgefallen beim Google-Reader. Also ich nutze den zum RSS-Feeds lesen, weil es geht schön auf dem iPhone und man kann sich einloggen und hat überall seine Feeds und alles, was dufte. Und plötzlich, das Feature gab es schon vorher, aber durch Google Buzz wird es jetzt auch genutzt, hat man ständig Follower beim Google-Reader. Und dann steht da oben, du hast so und so viele neue Follower. Und das ist ja auch bei Twitter, da kann man ja, wenn ein neuer Follower kommt, kann man das ja schön ignorieren. Man kriegt eine Mail, wenn man mag, man kriegt aber auch keine, wenn man keine mag. Bei Google wird man ständig mit der Nase drauf gedrückt. Hey, du hast vier neue Follower, ja danke. Und dann kannste ja alle angucken.
Das kann man nicht abschalten?
Ich hab wüsste das ja nicht wie. Und wenn man sie sich angeguckt hat, kann man sie auch nie wieder sehen. Man kann sich dann zwar eine Liste der Follower angucken, aber man kann nicht mehr gucken, welche sind jetzt die neuesten vier davon. Halt dich vorhin keine Zeit mehr anzugucken. Irgendwie ist das der Wurm drin. Ja, das ist Google. Ihr wart schon mal besser.
Naja, was soll man machen?
Alles hätte ich euch verziehen, aber nicht das.
So, haben wir noch was zu sagen zu Google Butz? Du hast das gar nicht benutzt.
Ich hab gedacht, ihr sagt nur, ob es cool ist. Und wenn es cool ist, dann ist es cool. Und wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Also ich kann nicht ausschließen, dass es Spuren von Coolness enthält. Aber...... kann Spuren von Coolness enthalten. Ich hab zumindest gemerkt, dass das so, wie es geboren wurde, kein No-Braner ist. Also man muss da schon irgendwie versuchen zu verstehen. Und es scheint schwierig zu sein, zu verstehen, was sie da gemeint haben. Und da sie auch selber so viel zurückgerudert sind, muss man jetzt glaube ich auch erstmal abwarten, wie weit sie da jetzt noch zurückrudern.
Mal gucken, was am Ende noch übrig bleibt.
Und nochmal zu dem Wave zurück. Nutzt ihr das Wave auch außerhalb von Sendungswaves irgendwie?
Ja, du meinst außer Mobile-Max oder generell? Naja, auch so für andere Podcasts. Wann auch immer ich mit Leuten zusammenkomme, und es geht darum, eine Agenda zu bauen.
Also ein bisschen gleichzeitig arbeiten.
Ja, also einfach diese Agenda zusammenzustellen. Da stelle ich häufig fest, dass Leute von sich aus auch Wave aufbringen. Also selbst wenn ich...
Also ist so ein Wave eigentlich ein bisschen mehr wie Interactive-Chatten, wo man nicht abwechselnd sich Zeilen schickt, wie bei Chatten, sondern im gleichen Text sozusagen.
Es ist nicht nur Elaborative Editing.
Ich nutze das als Google Docs-Ersatz eigentlich in erster Linie. Also diese Google Docs gibt es ja auch so eine Textfunktion und da kann man reinschreiben und kann auch gemeinsam gleichzeitig reinschreiben und alles dufte ab und hat halt keine Nachverfolgungsfunktion, mit der man gucken kann, was war jetzt die letzte Änderung, hab ich jedenfalls noch nicht entdeckt.
Diese History meiste.
Dieses zeig mir mal an, oder erinnere mich einfach, wenn was Neues passiert. Also zeig mir an, wenn jemand was ändert. Das finde ich sehr angenehm, dafür nutze ich gerne Wave. Wir arbeiten gemeinsam an einem Dokument und sag mir bitte Bescheid, wenn sich da was geändert hat.
Obwohl es dann an der Stelle auch wieder verwirrend ist, warum haben Sie eigentlich zwei solche Dienste? Warum greift Google Wave nicht sowieso in alles rein? Wieso kann so ein Spreadsheet, was ich auch für sich bearbeiten kann? Ja gut, mag ja sein, aber irgendwo da repliziert sich für meinen Geschmack dann schon wieder zu viel. Na ja, gut, lassen wir das sein. Reden wir lieber über Apple. Und zwar sollten wir vielleicht noch mal nach drei Wochen Diskussion über das iPad noch mal irgendwie überlegen, ob es irgendwas...
Ich hab immer noch keins.
Ob irgendjemand schon eine neue Idee gekommen ist, was das Ding ist oder nicht ist. Ist ja jetzt viel diskutiert worden.
Sofa-Surfing.
Sofa-Surfing. Na, interessanter Effekt, die Veröffentlichung zu haben, schien, ist ja der Buchmarkt. Also da brodelt's.
Der amerikanische Buchmarkt.
Der amerikanische Buchmarkt. Das ist ja auch der einzige, für den sie nun angekündigt haben, präsent zu sein.
Wobei in den letzten Tagen, oder weiß nicht, wie lange das schon ist, aber das Durchfall ist, dass dieses iBooks gar nicht Standardbestandteil des iPads ist. Also man muss erst so eine Spezial-Applikation herunterladen und dann hat man es. Das ist nicht gleich per Default mit drauf.
Wer hat das gesagt?
Stand letztens öfter irgendwo.
Naja, das ist nicht...
Woher soll man das wissen?
Das, äh, ja...
Niemand hat das?
Die Quellen, ja, nee, es gab eine Aussage. Ich glaube, es stand sogar auf einer Webseite von Apple.
Das iPad runtergeladen.
Der Album Store ist sozusagen ein App, das du erst mal runterladen musst. Solange du nicht Ami bist.
So wie die remote, die Litze auch aus dem App Store runter. Das macht ja auch Sinn. Doch, also erstens ist es für die Markttrennung, da sie das nur in den USA anbieten können, gibt es das Ding halt auch nur im App Store in den USA zu laden. Sie laden kein anderes OS, weil wenn sie ein OS-Update rausschicken, müssten sie ja für jedes Land ein anderes OS-Update machen und das wird so nicht funktionieren. Bei iTunes war es jetzt anders, von daher greift die Logik vielleicht auch nur begrenzt, aber das scheint für mich auf jeden Fall auch ein Grund zu sein. Und es hat natürlich für sie den Vorteil, dass sie auch häufiger updaten können, ohne jetzt jedes Mal ein OS-Update rauszubringen.
Stimmt, das sollten sie aber langsam auf die Beine kriegen.
Wie auch immer, das, denke ich, macht am Ende auch nichts aus. Dann haben sie auch, sagen wir mal, so eine Antitrast-Nummer weniger an der Backe. Wenn es jetzt wirklich da, wobei bei Musik hat sie das ja auch nie weitergeschert. Ich glaube, dieser Musikvergleich, den muss man auch erstmal ein bisschen außen vor lassen. Wie auch immer, Tatsache ist, dass bei Amazon auf jeden Fall die Nerven etwas blank lagen. Macht zumindest schwer den Eindruck.
Die haben ja irgendwie, wie war das? Die haben erst einmal einen ihrer Verlagen kurz rausgeschmissen, weil der gesagt hat, diese feste Buchpfeife.
Genau, wir möchten euren Deal nicht mehr mitmachen. Amazon hat so etwas daumenschraubige Verträge.
Die haben die nicht rausgeschmissen, sondern der Verlag hat gesagt, sie wollen ja höhere Preise.
Aber daraufhin hat Amazon sie für 48 Stunden nicht mehr im Angebot gehabt, was natürlich dann wiederum einen Sturm der Entrüstung aus dem Laserlager nach sich zog. Also vermute ich mal, dass das auf der anderen Seite...
Achso, genau. Dann haben sie kleinen beigegeben und gesagt, okay, die Preise sind jetzt aber eben höher, weil der Verlag wollte so.
Genau.
Also das haben sie ja nachgegeben eigentlich.
Jaja, sie haben nachgegeben. Amazon hat schwer nachgegeben und dann kam auch gleich der nächste an. Ihr ganzes Modell der Preiskontrolle, wie sie das bisher entfaltet haben, bricht, ob der drohenden Konkurrenz durch Apple... Na ja, ob es zusammenbricht, weiß ich nicht, aber es kommt auf jeden Fall gehörig durcheinander. Die Verlage haben jetzt einfach auch jemand anderen, auf den sie zeigen können. So nach dem Motto, wenn ihr es nicht verkauft, dann verkauft Apple das. Weil alle trauen Apple zu, eine enorme Marktmacht entwickeln zu können. Ob sie das tun werden, ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Aber definitiv macht sich keiner Illusion darüber, dass Apple auch in der Lage ist, einen Markt komplett von Null aufzuräumen. Das haben sie mit der Musik gezeigt und jetzt haben sie einfach alle schlackernde Hosen. Und das ist ganz offensichtlich, dass das jetzt hier der Grund ist, dass Amazon da macht. Und ich meine auch die anderen Moves, die sie ja schon vorher gemacht haben, dass sie jetzt ein Upstore ankündigen, dass sie irgendwie ihr Revenue-Modell dann da auch mit diesem 70-30-Prozent-Konzept machen. Also eigentlich kopieren alle Apple derzeit. Insbesondere auch mit dem Upstore-Ankündigung.
Das gehört auch gerade zur Saison.
Genau, das möchte ich jetzt einfach dazu. Ja, irgendwie ein Upstore. Wir sollten alle ja auch mal ein Upstore ankündigen. Genau, ihr braucht nichts mehr bei Apple einzustellen, irgendwie nur noch bei uns. Das kommt dann irgendwie. Die Beta kommt nächstes Jahr. Oder so.
Und wir testen das alles auf Herz und Gehör.
Genau, wir müssen erst noch mal gucken.
Ein Drittel geht an uns, zwei Drittel gehen an euch.
Nein, nein. Zwei Drittel gehen an uns.
Ich glaube, dass auf lange Sicht irgendwann in jedem Programm so ein Upstore drin ist.
Was in jedem Programm?
Man sollte App Store App Store machen.
In jedem eigenen Programm ist ein App Store. Du meinst so für Module und Plugins, oder was?
Ja, also zum Beispiel gibt es hier so ein, gibt es ja auch dieses, es gibt so ein Eagle, das ist ja so ein Layout-Programm. Da gibt es gerade von der Potsdamer Uni so ein, das heißt Fritzing. Und da hab ich auch gehört, die wollen da auch gleich, dass du, wenn du Bauteile da verbaust in deiner Platine und die Layout ist und so, kannst du auch gleich klicken, klicken, klicken und dann kannst du die auch gleich zusenden lassen. Nee, aber das ist halt, kannst du auch gleich in deinem Programm kaufen. Ich denke, alle Programme, wo du Zeug kaufen könntest, dass du das auch gleich innerhalb des Programms immer gleich kaufen kannst. Es kommt dann irgendwann vielleicht mal so eine Art App Store, API raus für Programme, dass sie gleich ihr Zeug dann so verbringen.
Aber das ist dann eher ein Store in App API.
Ja, also nicht im Sinne von du kaufst Apps, sondern du kaufst mit der App. Jede App ist ihr eigener Store. Ja, das denke ich hat Zukunft. Ich meine, das ist ja das, was Apple im Prinzip mit dieser zweiten Stufe in ihrem App Store...
Mit dem iBook ging's.
Dann haben sie ja den App Store schon best.
Genau, in App, tralala. Das ist definitiv wieder... Apple hat mal wieder alles früh begriffen. Und jetzt müssen alle hinterher.
Apple hat immer gar keinen Plan. Wir podcasten und alle anderen sicher auch. Die hören mit und denken sich, damn, gar nicht so blöd.
Google sollte uns mal dafür zahlen, dass wir einen Google Podcast machen.
Die sagen ja immer nix. Und alle Gerüchte schießen da aus dem Boden wie blöd. Und die brauchen ja nur noch zuhören. Und haben ja dann immer noch drei Monate Zeit.
Aber wenn sie überall zuhören würden, dann hätte das iPad ungefähr vier Firewire-Anschlüsse. Und würde ein voll aufgeblasenes Mac OS laufen lassen. Und dazu noch Windows 7 parallelisiert.
We don't do market research. We don't do consultants, sag ich nur.
Ich glaube, die hören sich sowas nicht an. Also wenn sie eine ganz tolle Idee haben, dann vielleicht, aber ansonsten.
Die lieben das auch selber, die Idee.
Steve Jobs hat ja irgendwann mal gesagt, es ist ja gar nicht so das Problem, tolle Ideen zu haben. Es ist das Problem, tolle Ideen abzulehnen und sich nicht so sehr auszulehnen, sondern wirklich den Fokus zu behalten.
Copy and paste. Aber bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei dem iPad und dem Buchmarkt. Es gab dann auch noch Diskussionen darüber und ich weiß gar nicht, was der aktuelle Zwischenstand ist, wie diese Bücher ausgeliefert werden. Und es scheint wohl auf jeden Fall so zu sein, dass... Ja, also Epubs, das haben sie ja gesagt. Und es gibt offensichtlich auch dann die Möglichkeit, DRM zu nutzen.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wer hätte das gedacht? Und es wird natürlich Fairplay sein. Wer hätte das gedacht? Also ihr Haus...
Es wäre eine Nachricht gewesen, wenn es kein Fairplay gewesen wäre.
Genau. Was ich allerdings jetzt nicht mitbekommen habe, wenn es darüber eine Aussage gab, oder wo ich vermute, dass es bisher noch gar keine gibt, ist, ob es dem Publisher auch frei steht, kein DRM zu verwenden. Da gibt es ja Vertreter, so wie O'Reilly zum Beispiel, die jetzt nicht auf der Liste der Verlage, mit denen sie dann gleich an den Start gegangen sind, losmarschieren. Also, O'Reilly will das ja nicht laut eigener Aussage. Ja genau, also ich denke mal, es wird einfach eine ganze Menge auch Content geben können, der kein DRM braucht oder will. Und ob das dann aber auch geht, wird sich zeigen. Meine Vermutung ist ja. Aber sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Hoffen wir es.
Hoffen wir das? Ja, ich denke, das wäre gut. Ich denke, das wäre gut. Die Frage ist, was das dann bedeutet.
Ob man die E-Pass zum Beispiel auch woanders lesen kann?
Du kriegst wahrscheinlich deine Credentials ins File. Dein iTunes-Account steht dann da mit drin.
Also du machst ja die DRM-freien iTunes-Songs. Das ist ja MPEG-4.
Ja, hat jeder eine andere Check-Summe auf seiner Datei.
Aber auch seitdem die keinen DRM mehr haben, sondern nur noch dieses Namens-Tagging, kann man die auch runternehmen und woanders hören. Das ging ja früher mit den richtigen DRM-Dingern. Die waren ja verschlüsselt und du konntest sie wirklich nur auf dem iPhone, iPod und auf deinem Rechner hören. Aber sonst nirgends. Also es ist ja schon vorbei eigentlich bei der Musik.
Wenn sie jetzt kein DRM machen, kann man mal weiter denken. Dann könnte ich mir diese Epubs kaufen und könnte die dann auch auf meinen Texta hochladen zum Beispiel. Hat jemand einen Texta? Niemand hat einen Texta, außer Texta. Das ist nicht im Verkauf, oder?
Also ich hab nichts gehört.
Ich auch nicht. Aber es gibt schon ganz viele, kann ich schon sagen.
Es gibt schon ganz viele? Aber die werden nicht verkauft, sondern nur verschenkt.
Nee, die werden ja verteilt für Leute, die mal so gucken wollen, die so wichtig sind.
Verstehe.
Es wird alles gut werden.
Ja, noch weitere Erkenntnisse zu dem, wie man ein iPad benutzen möchte. Habt ihr schon Kaufentscheidungen gefällt?
Mit 3G, weiß ich noch nicht, welche Version. Hängt davon ab, wie viel Geld ich dann gerade auf dem Konto habe.
Also mindestens 630 Euro.
Du auch?
Geht mir genauso. Also ich tendiere zu 32 GB, aber das hängt dann auch mal ganz...
Zu dem Mittelklassewagen.
Ja, Euro. Ich meine, die Preise stehen noch nicht fest, in Deutschland.
Also das kann doch einiges passieren.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie mit 1 zu 1 an den Start gehen. Das fände ich dann doch ein bisschen frech.
Also wie der Euro in letzter Zeit nachgelassen hat.
Du hast hier mehr Garantie und so.
Wie ist denn der Euro-Dollar?
1 zu 1,30 oder irgendwas.
Nee, 40 war schon 1 zu 1,40. Kann sein, dass wir ein bisschen gesunken sind, weil die Griechen machen uns ja alles kaputt.
Ja, die Griechen machen uns die Apple Store-Preise kaputt. Schmeißt die aus der E-Buch, oder?
Genau. Also 499 Dollar der nominelle Einstiegstarif.
Ohne 3G.
Ist heute 366 Euro.
Ja, aber das kannst du so nicht vergleichen. Erstens ist bei denen immer ohne Steuern, glaube ich, oder?
Netto, netto, netto, genau. Das ist der Netto-Preis.
Und zweitens haben die halt nicht 2 Jahre Garantie, so wie wir.
Wir haben auch keine 2 Jahre Garantie, wir haben 1 Jahr Garantie.
Ja, definitiv gibt es hier mehr Gewährleistung.
Gewährleistung ist aber das komplett andere als Garantie.
Garantie gibt es nämlich gar nicht. Und Gewährleistung ist das einzige, was es gibt.
Genau, Gewährleistung heißt nur, dass wir im Zweifelsfall Ersatzteile vorrätig haben müssen.
Also 499, netto, USA-Preis würde bei uns derzeit auf einen 436 Euro Brutto-Preis hinauslaufen. Das heißt, wenn sie gut sind, könnten sie da einen 449 draus machen.
Ja, aber du kannst ja ganz einfach gucken, wenn wir hier schon am Klicken sind, wie viel dort ein MacBook Pro kostet. Ich gucke mal gerade den Dollarpreis. Dann können wir da mal vergleichen, wie da schon das Verhältnis zwischen Dollar und Euro ist.
Das ist eigentlich ein guter Ansatz.
Und zum Beispiel hier das rechts unten, 17 Zoll in Dick kostet 2500 Dollar. Und dann gucken wir jetzt mal bei apple.de. Und das kostet, ihr dürft schon mal raten natürlich, 2500 Dollar, 17 Zoll. Was das kostet in Euro?
Sag doch einfach.
2500.
2300 Euro.
2300.
Also ganz bisschen runter, 10 Prozent.
Nicht mal. Ja, das würde auf so was hinauslaufen ungefähr. Das ist ja so 499 durch 25 mal 23. 40 Euro wehen ja circa. 459 Euro werden das da. Also könnten sie auch 450 machen. Ich meine, wenn sie dann keine Books anbieten und so, ist das Ding dann vielleicht wieder weniger wert. Und dann können sie dann irgendwie...
Kann sein, dass es genau so dahin vegetiert, wie bei uns hier der Apple-TV, der ja auch eine Weile nicht losstarten konnte, weil es hier nicht richtig den Movie-Markt gab und so. Aber es hat sich ja auch geändert jetzt.
Ich glaube, der vegetiert auch in Amerika schön vor sich.
Wenn der Chat jetzt irgendwie keine weiteren Fragen hat...
Ach, wir haben ja noch einen Chat.
Aber da wird auch nur... Da wird schon gegänt, ob wir den keine anderen Themen hätten. Doch, haben wir! Haben wir!
Wann sind wir durch mit dem iPad?
Ich würde schon sagen. Jetzt haben wir eine etwas religiösere, aufgeladene Diskussion vor uns.
Nehmen wir ganz kurz noch zum iPad. Ich hab mir das SDK runtergeladen und ich hab mal so ein bisschen auf dem virtuellen iPad rumgesurft mit dem Safari. Jetzt musst du auf deinen NDA aufpassen. Das war wirklich so. Ich hab das zwei Minuten gemacht. Okay, ich kauf mir so ein iPad. Es ist einfach Widerstand des Zwecklosses. Das iPad ist die Borg. Das macht echt Spaß, darauf zu surfen. Das macht echt einen tollen Eindruck. Also natürlich ist es auf dem Rechner ein zweifelsohner und zacken schneller, aber so dieses scrollt schön smooth und dann so die Bookmarksverwaltung ist echt gut durchdacht. Das macht echt einen sehr guten Eindruck. Das ist ein schicker Browser.
Ja, ich hab da nur so eine Video-Demo gesehen und muss sagen, ich finde es interessant, wie das iPad vom UI her doch versucht, auch so eine Melange aus iPhone und Mac zu sein.
Das sieht schon sehr Mac-ig aus eigentlich.
Genau, das ist Mac-iger als ich dachte. Und das geht ja eigentlich auch für die anderen Applikationen in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das Adressbuch sieht zwar auch sehr verspielt aus.
Ja, sieht anders aus, aber es ist halt schon so, dass es eben mehr versucht so die Spoof-Applikation zu sein.
Und von One Password gesehen? Die sehen ja auch sehr epic aus. Also so richtig Desktop-epic.
Ja, ich denke, das iPad leitet wirklich genau diese Generation ein. Das ist jetzt das Gedankenexperiment. Was ist denn, wenn wir die Komplexität aus Mac OS rausnehmen, was bleibt denn dann übrig?
Wenn wir den letzten Button auch noch entfernen.
Wenn ihr den letzten Button und die letzte Checkbox entfernt habt, werdet ihr wissen, dass man ein Touchpad nicht mit Handschuhen dienen kann.
Dass man mit dem iPad keine DVDs hinsetzen kann.
Kommen wir zu unserer religiösen Diskussion.
Airflash HTML5 oder was?
Ja. Na wenn das mal nicht Religion ist.
Das ist lustig, weil ich bin, jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen dafür werben. Ab 14 Uhr läuft die Sendung Breitband auf Deutschland Radio Kultur, wo ich ein kleines Interview gestern für befragt worden ist.
Du machst jetzt Werbung für eine Sendung, die parallel zu unserer Sendung läuft?
In Stereo hören. Ein Ohr, das Radio dran, klatscht, das andere Ohr und auf beiden Kanälen Max. Und wenn ich erst an der Macht bin, dann wird das immer so sein.
Max to the Max. Gut, ich hoffe du hast kluge Sachen gesagt. Du kannst ja schon mal ein Preview machen. Dann haben wir den Scoop sozusagen.
Da ging es darum, was ist HTML5?
Was ist denn HTML5?
HTML5 kann jetzt auch Video.
Das fragen sich viele Leute, was HTML5 ist.
Die Geschichte von HTML5 ist eine Geschichte voller Missverständnis.
Du meinst, es nimmt die Probleme da auf, wo sie entstehen?
Genau, der Videotech ist direkt in HTML-Code geembeddet.
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände.
Was schmilzt denn der Mund nicht?
Oh Gott, der kulturelle Abstieg von Mobile Max ist auch schon gesichert.
Wir konnten noch absteigen.
Nee, aber das ist noch mal ganz interessant. Lass uns noch mal grob zusammenfassen. Was ist denn eigentlich neu? Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, die großen Neuerungen sind aus meiner Perspektive, klar, das was jeder weiß. Es gibt ein Audio-Tech, es gibt ein Videotech. Sprich, es gibt generell die Möglichkeit, im Markup zu vermitteln, hier soll Video sein und hier soll Audio sein. Und wie es dann aussieht und in welchem Format es kommt, das sind auch nochmal ganz andere Fragen, aber das ist generell schon mal drin. Zweite große Sache ist, dass sie neue Strukturelemente drin haben, die die Seite einfach semantisch besser beschreibt. Also es gibt jetzt sowas wie, du kannst sagen, hier ist ein Sidebar, hier ist ein Header, hier ist ein Futter. Also generelle Elemente, die man sowieso immer wieder in Seiten findet. Und hier ist sozusagen der Kerninhalt. Dafür gibt es jetzt auch Tags. Du kannst das natürlich auch vorher irgendwie machen, abstrakt so mit DIV und dann deine eigenen Classes setzen und irgendwie darauf vertrauen, dass es irgendwelche Konventionen gibt. Jetzt gibt es einfach auch noch den Markup, mit dem man das tun kann. Und die dritte große Sache ist dieses Canvas-Element. Also da, wo du quasi SVG-Style, 2D-mäßig, Taker und Grafiken setzen kannst, aber halt so in der Art. Was in der Summe dann auch ein Großteil der Funktionalität von Flash repliziert?
Na ich würde erstmal das HTML5 ein bisschen anders rangehen. Und zwar aus der Perspektive. Vorher war ja quasi XHTML und XHTML war ja XML-basiert. Und das war so dieser Ansatz zu sagen, so wir stellen jetzt Regeln auf und wenn du Web-Designer sein willst, dann hast du nicht gefälligst noch diese Regeln zu halten. Ansonsten darfst du nicht mehr mitspielen.
Also die Akademikersicht.
So diese Akademikersicht. Und da das XHTML, würde ich sagen, kann man als gescheitert betrachten. Also es wird kein Browser heutzutage sagt, wenn irgendwas nicht XHTML-konform ist, dann rendere ich das nicht mehr. Oder HTML ist lang nicht tot, sondern es wird weiterverwendet. Eigentlich weiß niemand so richtig Bescheid. Und HTML5-Wallet, wenn ihr das eh nicht macht, dann brauchen wir auch nicht probieren, irgendwas euch aufzudrücken. Lass uns mal wieder einen Schritt zurückgehen und gucken, was braucht man denn im Web überhaupt. Und dann hat man festgestellt, es gibt mittlerweile viele Videos im Netz, also machen wir Video rein. Wir haben Handys mit Geolocation, also schmeißen wir Geolocation mit drauf. Und ihr wollt ein bisschen offline sein, also gibt es hier die Möglichkeit, offline Datenbanken anzulegen. Und das ist halt so dieses, was ich, HTML5 im Wesentlichen, der Paradigmenwechsel, mehr als offene Plattform. Und zu sagen, lass uns mal in den großen Sack alles reinpacken, was man irgendwie brauchen könnte. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so die 100%-Lösung ist, oder beziehungsweise das führt natürlich zu ganz eigenen Problemen. Aber, ja, das ist halt der Ansatz erstmal davon. Und geht dabei natürlich, wie du schon gesagt hast, mit Video und Audio und kann was, schön in die Richtung von dem, was Flash im Augenblick kann.
Der kann was, der kann was.
Und man braucht halt keinen scheiß Flash mehr.
Genau, das ist nämlich die große Frage, ob man keinen Flash mehr braucht. Die Diskussion in den letzten Wochen war ja etwas hysterisch schon auf beiden Seiten. Ausgelöst auch wieder durch das iPad. Wie, was, das iPad wird auch keinen Flash haben?
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das war ja wirklich die Überraschung. Aber alle haben sich nochmal, also ich glaube bei Adobe saß der Schock dann einfach nochmal tief. Weil das irgendwie mit dem iPhone, das fanden sie zwar nicht cool, aber das haben sie noch so ein bisschen verwinden können. Aber das iPad versucht ja natürlich auch, also adressiert jetzt eben auch so dieses größere Bildschirmformat, wo sie sich bisher einfach sicher gesehen haben.
Sie haben das Gefühl, dass es langsam eng werden könnte?
Es wird eng. Es wird eng. Diese ganzen Zahlen, die dann verschiedene Webseiten veröffentlicht haben, wie wenig Leute dann überhaupt noch Flash eingeschaltet haben, oder wie viele, sind auch irreführend.
Alle arbeiten mit getürkten Zahlen im ganzen Spielchen. Das ist doch absolut klar.
Vor allem auch so was wie Click to Flash heißt ja nicht, dass du kein Flash hast. Es heißt ja nur, dass du es sozusagen erst einschalten musst für das jeweilige Objekt.
Genau. Was Adobe so sagt, ohne uns kann man ja gar kein Video im Netz gucken, stimmt, im Augenblick habt ihr dann auch recht, aber dieses Fasse-Sagen irgendwie, dass zwei Drittel des Videocontents im Netz nicht betrachtbar wäre, ich glaube, da haben sie die Webseiten gezeigt. Ich würde behaupten, zwei Drittel des Contents im Web wird über YouTube angezeigt, und das läuft selbstverständlich auch ohne Flash. Also auf dem iPhone zumindest und mit der HTML5-Variante, die es von YouTube mittlerweile auch gibt, die immer noch exzellentell ist, klar, gar keine Frage.
Auch bei Vimeo?
Bei Vimeo genauso.
Die kommen jetzt auch alle damit, also die werden jetzt alle so ein HTML5-Verstand.
Dass jetzt Spiegel Online noch nicht morgen Videos im MP4-Standard bzw. im HTML5-Standard haben wird, gar keine Frage. Aber obwohl auch die werden relativ schnell hinterherkommen, dass irgendwelche kleinen Webseiten auch lange, lange noch Flash verwenden, aber die ganzen großen werden alle zu sehen, dass sie auch ohne Flash laufen. Genau das Gleiche sehe ich bei den Spielen, wo Adobe sehr stark argumentiert, ah, dann funktionieren 98% aller Spiele im Netz einfach nicht, wenn man keinen Flash hat. Ich glaube, das kann man so stehen lassen. Das ist eine Zahl, die ich vermute, die stimmt. Allerdings muss ich mal sagen, ich hab mir jetzt so ein Video angeguckt, das hab ich auch bei Twitter gepostet, wie irgendein Typ von Adobe Flash auf dem Android vorstellt und zeigt, und ein bisschen rum zeigt, und der geht dann auf so eine Flash-Spiele-Website und der hat sich ja vor seiner Demo rausgesucht, was er da anzeigt, und dann geht er da drauf und sucht sich natürlich genau das eine Spiel raus, für das man keine Tastatur braucht, für das man all diese Dinge nicht braucht, und dann hat er so ein Quiz-Spiel, dann muss er beim Fingernagel drauf tippen, weil die Elemente natürlich alle viel zu klein sind, um sie mit dem Finger zu treffen, und drückt trotzdem ständig daneben. Das heißt, diese Aussage, in dem Moment, in dem du Flash hast, kannst du all diesen Spiele-Content auf deinem Handy nutzen, der ist einfach Bullshit. Natürlich müssten die Sachen erst mal angepasst werden, damit sie auf deinem Handy vernünftig funktionieren. Und ob ich es nun dann für Flash anpasse oder für HTML5, klar, wenn man Flashspiel hat, ist es leichter, aufs Telefon zu portieren als komplett neu zu schreiben, aber jetzt so diese Aussage, das Web ist nur vollständig, wenn man Flash hat, das stimmt einfach nicht.
Das stimmt. Das sehe ich auch genauso. Allerdings, bei der Betrachtung der Diskussion ist mir auch noch etwas aufgefallen, es gibt da auch noch etwas, was nicht so einfach zu ersetzen ist, was derzeit in dieser ganzen Diskussion meiner Meinung nach so nicht stattfindet, und das ist einfach Streaming. Flash bringt ja nicht nur Video an sich, sondern es bringt ja auch Videostreaming. Und die meisten Sites nutzen das natürlich nicht. Bei YouTube hast du kein Streaming, du hast halt progressive Download.
In meisten Fällen?
Nee, du hast bei YouTube nie Streaming.
Ich glaube, die haben mittlerweile auch Live-Übertragungen. Ja, die haben auch diese Bass-Vorstellungen einfach noch live übertragen, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Okay, gut, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber du weißt, was ich meine. Also es ist halt einfach zu 99,9% ist das einfach.
Kein Streaming.
Geht es darum, ein Video per HTTP runterzuladen? Und im Bereich Streaming ist es natürlich insofern knifflig, als dass das, was heutzutage mit Flash Streaming macht, und jetzt, glaube ich, kommen wir auch an so einen Punkt, wo es für Adobe auch ein haariger Punkt wird, Adobe verdient natürlich sein Geld nicht mit Flash-Plugins. Adobe verdient sein Geld mit Backend-Software und mit Content-Authoring-Software.
Genau.
Creative Suite, Flash-Sachen machen und so weiter. Da könnte man ja auch noch sagen, ok, alles klar. Warum bauen sie ihr, ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt dieses Tool mit dem man, das heißt einfach Flash.
Es gibt Flash und es gibt Flex.
Und auch so ihr R und so weiter, ihre ganzen Sachen, die heute Flash voraussetzen. Da gibt es ja schon einen Migrationspfad hinzu. Das Ganze läuft dann auch in JavaScript. Es gibt in der ganzen JavaScript-Welt noch einen großen Mangel an Frameworks. Und es gibt wenig Grund aus meiner Perspektive für Adobe, warum sie nicht mittelfristig ihre ganzen Frameworks in ein HTML5 JavaScript-Environment hinein entwickeln sollten. Weil das ist ja genau das, was die Leute suchen. Die Leute wollen eine einfache Möglichkeit haben, standardkonform Anwendungen zu entwickeln. Und es gibt sehr viel konkurrierende Frameworks in der ganzen JavaScript-Welt. Aber ja, die sind alle sehr unterschiedlich und da hat sich auch noch lange nichts durchgesetzt. Da ist natürlich Adobe mit ihrem R und generell mit ihrem Flash haben sie einen riesen Vorsprung. Und angenommen, sie würden jetzt Creative Suite X rausbringen. Und du könntest alles das, was du bisher nach Flash georthert hast, einfach nach HTML5 JavaScript authoren. Und in jedem beliebigen Browser, einschließlich des iPhones, einschließlich Android, einschließlich Alm, einschließlich vielleicht sogar Windows Phone 7 targeten. Wer will denn dann noch Flash? Aber das tun sie nicht.
Ich glaube, das tun sie auch aus.
Da haben sie auch keine Druckmittel mehr.
Ich denke, naja, warum? Ich meine, sie wollen Geld verdienen.
Das ist der Markt der Zukunft.
Lass mich kurz zu Ende führen. Ich sehe, langfristig werden sie das tun müssen. Meiner Meinung nach kommen sie nicht drum herum. Die zweite Sache, mit der sie Geld verdienen, ist Streaming. Sie verkaufen diese Flash Streaming Server. Ich kenne jetzt ihre Umsatzzahlen nicht, aber das ist ein teures Produkt. Man sieht ja, es wird benutzt und so weiter. Da machen sie einfach Geld. Das ist natürlich ein Markt, in dem sie auch weiterhin bestehen wollen. Derzeit ist es so, es gibt drei oder vier verschiedene konkurrierende Streaming-Systeme, die so propagiert werden. Also diese klassische RTSP-Geschichte, das ist technisch schon lange da, funktioniert an sich auch, aber ist im Deployment irgendwie mager. Dann gibt es die HTTP-basierten Sachen, die meiner Meinung nach auch zukunftsträchtiger sind. Da gibt es das RMTP von Flash, also das, was Sie sich ausgedacht haben. Dann gibt es die HTTP-basierte Lösung von Microsoft in Silverlight. Und jetzt eben die von Apple propagierte Lösung in iPhone bzw. in Snow Leopard im QuickTime Player.
HTTP-Streaming auch.
Genau, alles technisch extrem vergleichbare Lösungen, die sich im Detail unterscheiden. Das hatten wir ja schon mal. Das heißt, da findet gerade der Krieg statt. Wer hat die technische Hoheit über Real-Time-Delivery von Video? Wir wissen alle, was Real-Time-Delivery von Video bedeutet. Das ist der Fernsehmarkt im Internet. Ich glaube, deswegen ist Adobe da auch so grätzig. Und will, wie es auch irgendwie möglich ist, diese Zeit, diesen Vorsprung, den sie haben, dadurch, dass sie der Client-Outlet sind, mit ihrem Flash-Plugin, das wollen sie sich so lange erhalten wie möglich. Deswegen schmerzt es eben auch so. Jetzt halte ich es small. Aber das ist so mein Punkt, wie ich die ganze Sache sehe.
Ich glaube, das sind zwei Punkte. Zum einen sehe ich, glaube ich, dass das, was Flash für einen großen Vorteil hat, sie haben DRM. Das ist für uns jetzt als Endanwender natürlich die totale Scheiße. Aber wenn du...
Auch im Videostreaming mal erzählen?
Im Videostreaming, ja. Richtig. Aber wenn du Fernsehfirma bist heutzutage und RTL bist, ich glaube, wenn da nicht das Wort DRM auftaucht, dann existiert die Technologie für dich im Augenblick nicht. Also meinst du das ernsthaft, dass irgendwie...
Weiß ich nicht. In meinem Live-Video ist es doch so, in dem Moment, wo es nicht mehr live ist, verliert es seinen Wert. Klar, Olympia kannst du irgendwie dann alles aufzeichnen, wenn es ohne DRM kommt. Aber es ist in dem Moment, wo du es aufzeichnest, verliert es schon seinen Wert. Es ist nur Wert in dem Moment, wo es live kommt. Und du kannst den Zugang zu diesen Live-Kanälen einfach über Registrierung, Passwörter und so weiter einfach sichern.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Argumentation, mit der du zugänglich bist, der diese Leute aber nicht zugänglich sind. Die wollen ihren Content schützen, die wollen die Vermarktungskette.
Aber Hulu und dieser ganze Kram, nutzen die wirklich DRM?
Ich glaube schon. Ich weiß es nicht, aber...
Die verdienen doch da Überwährung. Warum sollten sie das noch DRM-isieren?
Schon allein, um die Verträge auszuhandeln mit den entsprechenden Studios, die den Content produzieren. Die machen ja auch nicht alles selber. Ich glaube, die haben ganz furchtbare Angst davor, dass irgendjemand das Zeug runterlädt, einfach die Werbung rausschneidet. Ansonsten würde ja nichts dagegen sprechen, einfach den ganzen Scheiß per Beton rauszuschmeißen. Wenn sie sagen, wir machen da Werbung rein und dann kann man sich das Ganze angucken. Die wollen die Kontrolle drüber haben. Das sind Firmen, die darauf basieren, dass sie Kontrolle über Content haben. Und die werden sie nicht ohne guten Grund abgeben.
Ja gut, der gute Grund ist natürlich der, dass sie eben mit ihrem kleinen Modell nicht durchkommen. Danach sieht es halt aus. Auf dem iPhone sind sie nicht präsent. Theoretisch haben sie einen Fuß in der Android-Welt, die sicherlich größer wird. Genau, mit Flash. Mir geht es jetzt um Adobe und Flash. Und ich denke, keine Ahnung, was sie da jetzt gerade in ihren Labs haben, aber bisher gibt es nichts funktionierendes. Es gab ja auch die Meldung, dass Firefox auch Flash rausgeschmissen hat aus ihrem Deployment für Myemo. Aus Nokia Formats Gründen.
Für den Mobile Firefox.
Heißt der irgendwie anders? Hat der noch einen anderen Namen?
Der hieß Ferret oder so was. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie er heißt.
Am Ende wird es Firefox heißen, wahrscheinlich aus brandigen Gründen.
Gibt es überhaupt schon einen vernünftigen Flash-Player für ARM? Android behaupten zwar immer, das steht kurz vor der Tür, dann nennt man es für ARM.
Für ARM. Vernünftigen? Ich hab noch nie einen vernünftigen Flash-Player.
Wieso optimierte Version, die Adobe da rausbringen wollte?
Für Android gibt es meines Wissens nach noch keinen Flash-Player. Keinen vernünftigen.
Es ist klar, dass Adobe dran entwickelt.
Klar, klar.
Also sie tun das. Ob sie das mit Erfolg tun?
So wie unser Beta-Appstore bald rauskommt.
Sie haben schon was, was wir vorführen könnten.
Ja gut. Aber de facto sind sie noch nicht da.
Sie haben noch nicht gesagt, damit gibt es einen Flash-Player für Android.
Ich trau ihnen auch zu, dass sie Leute haben, die schon wissen, was sie tun. Am Ende sind sie auch in der Lage, vielleicht irgendwas abzuliefern, was nicht total Sack-Performance-mäßig ist. Das ist durchaus vorstellbar. Derseits sieht es nicht so aus, aber es ist vorstellbar.
Ich finde es ganz lustig, dass sie die ganze Zeit Apple bashen und sagen, ihr lasst uns nicht auf eure iPhone. Und sie hätten, selbst wenn Apple jetzt sagen würde, ich glaube, die hätten einfach nichts, was auf dem iPhone laufen würde. Ja gut, aber sie würden sofort dran setzen, sie würden alle Ressourcen draufschmeißen, ohne jede Frage. Aber sie haben auch für Palm noch nichts, sie haben auch für Android noch nichts.
Aber es ist old technology und Flash ist eine Sackgasse. Und das bedeutet einfach nur, dass man Adobe die Kontrolle über Streaming-Content im Internet überlässt. Weil ich denke, die Kontrolle über progressive Download verlieren sie bereits. Das ist sozusagen weg bei Streaming. Das ist die einzige Sache, wo derzeit Flash noch einen Vorteil hat. Weil das ist halt so noch nicht da. Ich habe allerdings gehört, ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, dass man auf dem iPhone, jetzt muss ich mal kurz nachdenken, dass ich nichts Falsches sage, dass es auch möglich ist, in einem Video-Tech iPhone Streaming zu machen. In der Seite, in ein Video-Element hinein, HTTP Streaming zu machen. Und die HTML5-Spec lässt das ja auch offen. Beziehungsweise, ihr interessiert es sogar explizit, da ist von Videokonferenzen die Rede. Und das ist ja noch nichts anderes als Livestreaming. Das heißt, wir werden, also ich vermute, dass wir mit dem iPhone OS 4.0 und wahrscheinlich dann auch mit dem iPad, weil ich denke mal, das iPad wird, naja, wenn es nicht mit iPhone erst 4.0 rauskommt, dann wird das schnell ein Upgrade bekommen, wenn das neue iPhone draußen ist, was vermutlich, also das ist jetzt geraten, aber das ist so das, womit ich eigentlich derzeit rechne. Und wir werden unter anderem mit diesem iPhone OS 4.0 sehen Video inline in Webseiten. Und sie werden das auf dem iPhone konzeptionell rauslassen, wegen einfach dieser Größen- und Bedienungsproblematik. Deswegen machen sie es auch jetzt schon so. Das heißt, du klickst noch mal drauf und dann hast du das Video immer full-skill, aber auf dem iPad wirst du das inline sehen können. Und dann wäre ich auch nicht überrascht, wenn eben auch Live-Streaming möglich ist. Dass sie mit dem iPhone HTTP-Streaming das irgendwie macht. Mit der Macht, die das iPhone hat und die das iPad gegebenenfalls auch entwickeln wird, hat natürlich ihr Streaming-Ansatz, der ja ein offener ist. Der ja keine proprietäre Lösung ist. Große Chancen im Kampf um die Standardsvorherrschaft Fortschritte zu machen. Ich sag das mal ganz zurückhaltend, ohne dass ich jetzt gleich wieder den Sieg ausrufe. Ja, also das ist das, wie ich das sehe. Und ich halte das für eine sehr spannende Diskussion. Für mich ist Flash einfach dein Technology. Das ist einfach durch. Und ich mach das auch daran fest, dass eben auch diese JavaScript-Welt gerade sich enorm zusammenrauft. Da ist sehr viel in Bewegung. Und es gibt keine Programmiersprache, für die derzeit so heftig entwickelt wird, wie für JavaScript.
Das hat ja schon einen Grund, warum ihre JavaScript-Engines auch so schnell gemacht haben. Sonst könnten sie ja auch nicht gegen Flash anstinken, weil sie muss natürlich auch eine Speedy-Alternative haben.
Genau.
Und mittlerweile sind sie halt schneller.
Und mittlerweile gibt es ja auch so erste Ansätze von wegen JavaScript wird auf der GPU ausgeführt. Scheiße, muss ich mal raussuchen. Ich hoffe mal, ich finde das jetzt noch so rasch auf die Schnelle. Also es ist alles noch total Labor und weiß ja toll was. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, was man in einem fertigen Produkt runterladen kann.
Aber ich habe davon nichts gehört, aber würde mich interessieren.
Dass man damit dann auch schön irgendwelche...
Wer hat da was wie wo und welchen Rahmen wie wo gemacht?
Da haben wir es. JavaScript running on the GPU. Hören Sie uns live zu, wie wir im Internet surfen.
Gibt es eigentlich auf Twitter irgendwie Mobile-Mix-Diskussionen mit Lattenzaun Mobile-Mix? Das müssen wir gleich mal schauen. Ich habe gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Ganz schön langer Tag.
Was, was, was?
Ich überlege gerade, ob es irgendwie... Doch, Lattenzaun Mobile-Mix ist tatsächlich in Benutzung. Warum auch nicht?
Ich habe sogar die Suche dazu abonniert.
Na Mensch, unsere Witze zitiert. Das ist doch schon mal was. Genau, ich verfolge mal Lattenzaun Mobile-Mix.
Also der hat hier irgendwie in Jetpack das Ganze eingebaut. Jetpack to Cuda.
Dich lässt das kalt, wa, Dennis?
Flash ist aus.
Du bist schon drüber hinweg.
Ich hab Click to Flash und das rockt.
Aber du klickst ja auch manchmal drauf auf Click to Flash.
Also du klickst es ja schon.
Ich mein, sonst könntest du ja das Flash Plug-In deinstallieren. Soweit bist du noch nicht.
Ne, weil... Click to Flash hat so einen Installer, das ist doch viel schicker. Also was weiß ich, wo das Flash Plug-In ist.
Na, das ist in deinem OS, das liefert dir Apple mit aus und aktivisiert es auf 5.2.
Da müsste ich ja da rumforschen und manchmal will man ja vielleicht schon. Aber eigentlich fast immer nur für Videos und da die Click to Flash Leute voll cool sind, haben die ja da was gedreht. Und bei YouTube zum Beispiel, da kommt ja gleich der QuickTime Player.
Und auch bei... Und bei beiden, nicht im Fullscreen.
Also ich muss doch Fullscreen, oder?
Geht das mit QuickTime mittlerweile?
Das finde ich ja echt peinlich, dass der QuickTime Du kannst bei Click to Flash das so anklicken, dass er dann halt den QuickTime-Player startet und der macht das dann Fullscreen. Aber du kannst nicht direkt aus dem Browser heraus Fullscreen machen.
Dass wir da nicht diesen kleinen Button eingebaut haben, macht das mal Fullscreen?
Das ist einfach eine Limitierung der APIs derzeit noch. Das ist etwas, was so noch nicht ohne Weiteres geht.
Aber da muss man mal sagen, das kriegt Flash hin.
Aber auch nur mit Spezialerlaubnis. Flash kriegt das hin.
Aber bei QuickTime geht es, glaube ich, meines Wissens derzeit nicht. Aber vielleicht hat es auch einfach irgendjemand noch nicht den notwendigen Schritt gemacht. Aber das ist knifflig. Es geht auch aus JavaScript heraus nicht. Du kannst auch in JavaScript nicht sagen, mach mal jetzt Fullscreen. Es geht nur, wenn überhaupt, für Videos. Es gibt zum Beispiel diesen sublimen Videoplayer. Der richtig irgendwie Open Source JavaScript basiert. Der ist jetzt noch nicht zum Download verfügbar. Der ist angekündigt und es gibt so ein paar Demos. Das sieht ziemlich geil aus. Da kannst du irgendwie Fullscreen machen, aber du kannst das halt nur machen für ein Video. Du könntest jetzt nicht sagen, ich mach jetzt ein Fullscreen User Interface für alles mögliche, including Video, wie das bei Flash geht.
Das ist halt noch nicht da. Ja, aber ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass Apple ganz gute Kontakte zu den Machern von Safari haben soll. Ich hab das für ihr QuickTime wahrscheinlich im Zweifelsfall schon hinbekommen, dass es eine Fullscreen-Funktion hat.
Da sieht man mal wieder, dass das eine gute Sache ist. Alle Systemkomponenten in einem Haus zu haben. Dann kann man nämlich da basteln. OS und Safari und alles, wobei wir bei Microsoft immer gemeckert haben. Aber das ist ja schon nicht schlecht.
Ich hab da nie gemeckert bei Microsoft. Also was das betrifft. Also diesen Vorwurf, dass sie ihren Browser nicht mit ausliefern dürfen, den hab ich nie verstanden. Da steht, dass Steve Jobs höchstpersönlich Mobamex hört. Insbesondere Ausgabe 39.
Wir haben wieder Tethering.
313 war ja die Autonummer von Donald Duck.
Ich bin froh, dass sie nicht so lange bei 311 auf 311 gegangen sind oder so was.
Die erfolgreichste Version normaler Zeitung.
iPhone OS 95 danach. Auch immer noch nicht gefallen, der Groschen.
Windows 311, Novell 311. Du weißt, 311, es gibt immer wieder so. Noch nichts wollen mitbekommen? Lassen wir das. 313 ist das letzte iPhone OS-Dingsbums. Und sie haben das halt eingebaut, was ich hier auch an diesem Tisch höchstpersönlich gefordert habe, dass sie für Unlocked Phones einfach mal diese Tethering wieder einschalten müssen. Was sie uns genommen haben.
Mit dem 311. Nee, nie gegeben.
Doch, mit 3.0 hatten wir es ja.
Ah ja, stimmt.
Ja, mit 3.0 hatte ich es. Ich hab die ganze Zeit nicht geupgraded auf 3.1. Und jetzt konnte ich das endlich tun. Und es gibt wieder.
Wie ist das eigentlich? Du hast jetzt auf 3.1.3 geupgraded und du hattest von vornherein die Option, dass du Tethering aktivieren konntest?
Ich hab das jetzt nicht vor dem Stretch gemacht. Also ich hatte glaube ich noch dieses Profil da geladen.
Ich kann euch noch meine Geschichte erzählen.
Oh ja, bitte erzähl uns mal eine Geschichte.
Also ich hatte ja 3.0, Tethering ging, kam das 3.1-Update, ich getwittert, jung geht es, Tethering noch? Und so ein paar Hanseln, die haben bestimmt zugehört, die Hanseln. Aber egal, die haben gesagt, und ihr seid wirklich schuld, die haben gesagt, dass Tethering geht noch.
Ja, ja, genau das hatte ich auch.
Alles klar, ich 3.1 installiert und auch wenigstens, wenn mein Progress bei Hecken läuft, ach nee, geht doch nicht. Dann hatte ich 3.1, kein Tethering mehr. Und dachte, okay, Schimpfwörter wieder weggelassen jetzt. Ist halt so, und bis 3.1.2 hatte ich halt kein Tethering. Und es ging auch nicht mehr mit Profiles. Du konntest rumschieben, wenn du wolltest. Tethering war irgendwie gestorben. So, dann kam 3.1.3. Ich installierte es, weil ich musste mir jetzt über nichts mehr Gedanken machen. War eh alles zu spät, kann ich ja immer die neuesten Updates installieren und so. J-Break und so ein Schnickschnack hab ich alles nicht. Mein Phone ist dicht. Und dann haben die geschrieben, Tethering soll gehen. Ging nicht. Gemacht, getan. Einstellungen resettet. APNs neu eingestellt und so. Ging nicht, ging nicht, ging nicht. Stunde lang rumprobiert, ging nicht. Und da meinten aber Leute weiterhin, also nicht nur hier bei unserem Freund, hier, wie heißt er, die Mac-Seite, die News-Seite, die deutsche... FSC-Karlok. Dennis. Bookmark-Completion.
Du bist so ein Mac-Surfer-Typ, das finde ich auch echt cool.
Ich lese FSC-Karlok, da steht's, genau. Und ich klicke halt immer nur. Und da stand jedenfalls, dass es geht. Im Zweiten stand, dass es geht. Ich dachte, okay, wenn es bei denen überall geht, dann muss es bei mir auch gehen. Hab rumgespielt und rumgespielt und es ging einfach nicht. So, und dann bin ich irgendwie draufgekommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich jetzt auch Twitter-Tipps bekommen habe oder ob ich so draufgekommen bin, dass ich halt dieses Profile, was man da bei 3.0, was man da eingespielt hat, dieses Carrier-Profile, das konnte man sicher selber machen. Auch mit diesem Carrier-Logo und was man für Einstellungen nimmt. Und da hatte ich halt eins bei mir drauf. So, und das war anscheinend irgendwie noch da und das ging nicht weg. Ach, auch mit Netzwerkeinstellung zurücksetzen. Es ging nicht weg. Also, letzter Tipp. Hab ich gemacht, alles zurücksetzen. Also so komplett komplett. Also nicht nur Einstellungen löschen, sondern Daten auch löschen. Sodass wirklich das Ding komplett leer ist und du wieder auch aktivieren musst.
Aber dann spielst du doch wieder deinen Backup ein, oder hast du dann wirklich so alles?
Ja, aber Apple backupt ja nichts, was nicht von ihnen ist. Das heißt, die Carrier-Profiles werden nicht gebackupt. Anscheinend.
Aber es backupt deine Daten?
Ja, das macht er. Das war alles okay. Aber dieses Carrier-Profile hat das nicht überlebt. Also wieder eingespielt, dann ging alles eingestellt. Ging es trotzdem erstmal nicht, weil ich noch einen kleinen Fehler hatte. Habe ich ja letztens auch getwittert. Ich habe bei diesem MMS-Proxy und so, da gehört das Http nicht mit davor. Ich habe mich bei einer Webseite da verguckt. Habe ich dann auch noch rausgefunden.
Das heißt, du hast dann wieder ein Carrier-Profile eingespielt?
Nee, ich habe gerade etwas verwechselt. Das MMS-Problem war nochmal was anderes. Aber das Tethering, das geht.
Also es ging dann sofort? Ohne, dass du ein Carrier-Profile einspielen musstest?
Ah, okay. Ich bin auf diese üblichen Seiten. Es gibt hier ein paar Seiten, die ein Carrier-Profile anbieten. Also bei mir ging es auch nicht auf einen Hieb. Und dann habe ich mir da genauso wie bei 3.0 einfach nochmal so ein Carrier-Profile eingebaut.
Ich bräuchte nochmal so ein Carrier-Profile, fällt mir gerade ein, weil ich immer noch so dieses Problem habe mit, ihr wisst schon, Anrufweiterleitung.
Jaja, das habe ich seitdem auch wieder. Das hatte ich ja unter 3.1.
Und mit welchem Profil hast du jetzt gute Ergebnisse mit O2?
Also, das habe ich auch noch. Diese Nachricht habe ich auch nicht. Ich bin nicht losgewonnen. Wenn da mal jemand einen guten Tipp hat, gerne her damit.
Warte, das heißt das mit 3.1.3? Weil ich habe das Carrier-Profile jetzt weggelassen. Mein iPhone ist jetzt wirklich total Apple-mäßig. Aber du hast wieder so ein Carrier-Profile eingespielt.
Und danach ging es auf Anhieb.
Jaja, jetzt geht das wieder. Das war ja sozusagen das, was sie verhindert haben. Auch auf einem Unlocked-Phone haben sie ein nicht-signiertes Profil abgelehnt. Und das haben sie jetzt wieder geändert. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt ein nicht-signiertes Carrier-Profile einspielen, wenn du ein Unlocked-Phone hast. Wenn du ein Locked-Phone hast, wenn du also ein T-Mobile-Phone hast.
Dann natürlich nicht.
Dann geht es halt nicht. So nach dem Motto, du hast es da gekauft, jetzt musst du damit auch leben. Und wenn dir das T-Mobile das nicht gibt, dann...
Hat das sicher was mit dem Unlocked und mit dem Locked zu tun? Weil ich bilde mir ein, dass es auch bei Unlocked-Phones mit T-Mobile-Karten gibt es kein Tethering.
Ach so, dass es sozusagen auch noch mit dem Netz zu tun hat, in dem du eingebucht hast, nicht nur mit dem Locked.
Das, was man Tethering hat, steht ja in diesem Carrier-Profile drin, ob man das darf oder nicht. So, und wenn es natürlich, selbst wenn du ein Unlocked-Telefon von der Telekom hast, dann wird ja trotzdem dein Telekom Carrier-Profile benutzt. Und da steht ja erstmal drin, du darfst nicht. Das heißt, das müsstest du dir ja auch erstmal neu draufschieben oder editieren. Also, per Default ist es bei denen erstmal nicht. Und wenn es aber unlockt ist, kannst du ja ein anderes Telekom Carrier-Profile draufschieben.
Also ich hab gehört, dass Tethering nicht gehen soll einfach bei iPhones mit, also bei Angelockten. Ich weiß nicht, woran es jetzt scheitert, aber kann natürlich sein, dass man einfach nur das richtige Profil einspielen muss und alles das dufte.
Das ist eigentlich kein Rat, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher.
Das ist unser Stand der Dinge, ihr dürft uns in den Kommentaren dann entsprechend auseinandernehmen und Links zu eurem Vikings-Profile bieten.
Ich, wenn ich jetzt einen Call mache, dann auch wieder diese Anruf weiterleiten und kriegen müsste, weil ich ja kein Carrier-Profile mehr drauf habe. Ist mir jetzt gar nicht aufgefallen in letzter Zeit. Hab ich etwa seit zwei Wochen schon wieder nicht telefoniert.
Würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten, wenn das nicht der Fall ist. Aber wir sollten jetzt das vielleicht nicht während der Sendung versuchen, es komplett zu debuggen. Dann können wir ja nachher noch mal schauen und dann haben wir schon wieder ein Thema.
Auf jeden Fall 3.1.3 geht jetzt mit Tethering. Und man kann Carrier-Profiles einspielen und sich zur Not dann auch die Anruf weiterleitungs-, den Alert da irgendwie wegmachen, wenn man möchte. Und eigene Logos setzen und Schnick Schnack.
Nächstes Thema. Steve war sauer.
Steve war sauer.
Und hat rumgeschimpft.
Er hat gesagt, was ich ihm schon seit Monaten, Jahren sage.
Steve hat gesagt, dass Apple evil ist?
Nein, er hat gesagt, dass Google evil ist. Aber das sagst du auch schon seit Monaten.
Nein, ich hab mich gerade vertan.
Also was denn jetzt?
Na, weil da stand Apple und Google. Nein, Google ist evil. Klar, natürlich, natürlich.
Ich hab Eric Schmidt gesagt, dass er sagt, dass Apple evil ist.
Du hast ja auch gesagt, dass Apple evil sei. Für dich sind ja beide evil.
Ja, aber Google ist schrumpf. Alle evil außer Mutti.
Wirklich?
Weil?
Na, Apple zieht mir nur das Geld aus der Tasche und ich denke immer, damn, warum ist die Scheiße so teuer? Aber sonst geht es eigentlich. Aber bei Google, die wollen gar nicht mein Geld, sondern die wollen meine Daten. Und ich finde, mein Geld ist mir gar nicht so wichtig. Meine Daten sind mir wichtiger. Meine Privatsphäre und Intimsphäre sind mir viel wichtiger als ein paar Dollar.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute diese Auffassung generell teilen würden.
Nein, glaube ich auch nicht, weil die gehen ja alle bei Aldi einkaufen.
Bei Aldi einkaufen ist so schlimm jetzt auch wieder nicht. Aber lass uns nicht auch noch diese Gesprächszene-Karte ziehen. Tatsache ist, er hat offensichtlich in einer Situation, das war bei Apple, hat er sich dazu geäußert und es wurde auf verschiedene Arten kolportiert. Am Ende, so ich gelesen habe, war nur die Aussage verbirgt, es gebe Gruppen bei Google, Teile von Google, so ähnlich war die Formulierung, die Apple gerne auswischen wollen.
Sorry fürs Unterbrechen. Was ich gehört habe, was er gesagt haben soll, macht euch nichts vor, Google will das iPhone töten und wir werden das nicht zulassen.
Das war die erste Variante, die kolportiert wurde. Bei Daring Fireball gab es Quellen, die meinten, so genau war es nicht formuliert, sondern es ging um Teile von Google. Damit war wahrscheinlich eher die Android-Gruppe gemeint. Also es ist nicht so...
Da brauchen sie sich doch gar keinen Kopf machen. War das nicht so, dass das Nexus One irgendwie schleppend verkauft wird?
Ach, das wird nicht schleppend verkauft.
Ich meine, es mag jetzt Überlappung geben, aber grundsätzlich ist es schon so, dass Apple und Google sich vollständig unterschiedlichen Geschäftsbereichen zuwenden. Es mag sein, dass der Kauf einer Mobile-Advertisement-Firma von Apple in eine Richtung zielt, wo sie sich mehr Konkurrenz machen könnten in der Zukunft. Wobei mir noch nicht so ganz klar ist, wie das dann aussehen sollte. Es ist natürlich auch so, dass der Vorstoß von Android in irgendeiner Form Apple auch betrifft. Aber auch da sehe ich das eher so, Android vernichtet eher alle anderen Konkurrenten als das iPhone. Dass Android jetzt dem iPhone geschadet hätte in irgendeiner Form, das kann ich einfach so derzeit noch nicht ablesen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Ich denke eher, das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Googles Auftritt zeigt, dass man eben auch ohne das Apple-Modell durchaus diesen Trend zum Smartphone mit unterstützen kann. Und das hilft irgendwie beiden. Die Leute wollen einfach jetzt immer mehr Smartphones haben und auch Leute, die mit einem iPhone nicht glücklich sind, haben eine Alternative und das hilft auch Apple. Im Hinblick auf offene Standards, Streaming etc. Das ist die Diskussion, die wir eben schon hatten.
Das mag ihnen im Augenblick durchaus helfen, aber ich glaube, dass Apple und Google dennoch Konkurrenten sind. Weil ich sage, dass die Konkurrenten sind?
Du bist halt hier der Android-Verteidiger. Aber ok, er fängt jetzt zu Ende.
Aber leg erst das Messer wieder auf den Tisch.
Es ist einfach, Google und Apple machen beide Smartphone-Betriebssysteme. Google und Apple sind beide im Videogeschäft tätig in irgendeiner Form. YouTube im Augenblick noch kostenlos. Google mit YouTube kostenlos. Wobei es aber da auch die ersten Bezahlungenmelde gibt. Apple auch ganz deutlich. Google hat sich ein Stück weit...
Aber es sind schon moviemäßig ganz schön unterschiedliche Geschichten. Also Apple hat eher Movieserien und Google ist mehr bei anderem Content, auch wenn er Geld kosten sollte. Aber es ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen aufgetrennt.
Bisher noch. Aber das geht ja... Ich meine, YouTube... Über lange Zeit gab es nur kostenlosen Content.
Eigentlich schaffst du recht.
Langsam kommst du dahin.
Warum soll man nicht irgendwann seine Movies und Serien auch im Browser gucken, wie Google die da anbietet?
Genau. Google und Apple haben beide so ein... haben Zahlmodelle mit zahlenden Kunden. Also so haben beide die Hand in einer Kreditkarte. Wo hat Google die? Google hat dieses Checkout-System in Amerika.
Wollen wir mal ehrlich, Google hat doch so richtig mit Endkunden? Haben die mit Endkunden zu tun?
Die hatten mal einen MP3-Store, den haben sie wieder dicht gemacht. Da sind sie noch nicht so richtig drin. Sie haben den Market auf Android.
Also sie probieren es, aber sie haben wenig Erfolg. Also das muss man sagen.
Also sie haben bisher noch nicht den Erfolg, den Apple hat, aber auf jeden Fall so dieses...
Sie haben überhaupt gar keinen Erfolg. Also ich meine, weder ist Checkout irgendwie eine nennenswerte Alternative zu PayPal geworden, Checkout hat einfach keine Verbreitung. Punkt. Die meisten Leute wissen wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es in Amerika aussieht, aber...
Google hat einfach eine ganze Menge Fail am Start. Das Einzige, was wirklich gut funktioniert, ist ihr Werbemarkt. Punkt.
Und Google und Apple... Microsoft, Entschuldigung, Microsoft verdient irgendwie OS und Office und die verdienen Werbung.
Ja, genau. Und Apple verdient in allen anderen Segmenten.
Das stimmt. Und Google und Apple sind jetzt beide irgendwie im Buchmarkt drin. Auch da natürlich erst mal von zwei komplett unterschiedlichen Seiten. Aber sie, die einen scannen Bücher ein und stellen sie ins Netz und die anderen verkaufen Bücher.
Ja, aber das ist doch kein Markt. Also ich meine, weil Google diese Bücher scant, das ist ja für sie kein Revenue-Modell. Noch nicht heißt, nein. Noch nicht heißt vielleicht irgendwann mal in der Zukunft unter Umständen vielleicht. Aber jetzt halt gerade nicht. Wenn wir jetzt analysieren, wo sind die Konkurrenten, dann akzeptiere ich einfach nicht, dass man sagt, man vergleicht hier Äpfel und Birnen. YouTube hat ja auch Videos und Apple verkauft Movie-Serien. Das ist einfach was anderes. Das heißt, derzeit kann man sich zwar alle möglichen Szenarien ausdenken, wo sie theoretisch unter Umständen um denselben Markt kämpfen, de facto tun sie das derzeit aber fast nirgendswo. Der einzige wirkliche Bereich, wo man sagen kann, wo sie es tun, ist Handys. Google hat ein Android-Phone, wo sie ihren eigenen Brand drauf haben. Sie bauen das nicht. Sie ingenieren das auch nicht. Sie haben wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Anforderungen darauf, wie das zu sein hat. Oder eine Mindestqualitätsnorm und so weiter. Und da werden sie sicherlich in Zukunft auch noch mit anderen Firmen ins Bett gehen. Da wird ja auch gerade gemunkelt, dass es ein Nexus 2 geben soll, was dann irgendwie von Motorola produziert wird und so weiter. So kann ich mir das auch vorstellen. Und natürlich ist jedes verkaufte Android-Phone potenziell vielleicht auch kein verkauftes iPhone. Auch wenn ich derzeit denke, wer ein iPhone, also wer irgendwie affin ist, sich eins zu kaufen, wird sich wahrscheinlich eins kaufen. Dem wird das Nexus One nicht unbedingt davon abhalten. Es sei denn, er ist Nerd. Aber es ist eine Entscheidung zwischen einem Blackberry und einem Windows Phone und einem Palm. Da, denke ich mal, kannibalisiert Google sehr viel mehr mit ihrer Android-Produktpalette. Wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, das ist alles voller Spannung, aber ich akzeptiere derzeit diese Sicht mit, dass die jetzt totale Konkurrenten werden.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass die sich aus Blut bekämpfen.
Die profitieren voneinander mehr, als dass sie derzeit in Konkurrenz stehen.
Konkurrenz belebt ja bekanntlich das Geschäft. Man sieht, wie deutlich die Messer rausgeholt werden. Auf allen Seiten. Wie Steve Jobs gegen Google wettert. Bei Google kriegt man es ja auch mit. Jetzt kann plötzlich Multitouch gehen. Warum ging bisher Multitouch nicht auf diesen ganzen Android-Telefon? Plötzlich kommt ein Update raus und plötzlich geht es einfach.
Vielleicht haben sie ihre Angst überwunden.
Vielleicht denken sie sich auch einfach, lass die mal kommen. Dann doch diese öffentlich korportierten Sachen, die sie möglicherweise mit der nächsten iPhone-Version statt Google Bing nutzen als Standard-Suchmaschine. Weiß ich nicht, auch ein Schweinegeld einbringt. Das ist schon alles so. Das ist nicht so, wir sind gute Kumpel und machen alles zusammen.
Warum sollten sie nicht mit der Bing-Keule wedeln, wenn sie da in Verhandlungen stehen? Das ist ja ganz klar.
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Das würden sie sogar machen, wenn sie sie nicht nutzen wollen.
Ja, natürlich, das ist doch gar keine Frage. Aber sie holen die... Das wird schon offener.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir weiter vom Fleck kommen in dieser ganzen Diskussion.
Das ist ja noch nicht vorbei, weil Steve hat ja nicht nur über Google erzählt. Er hat ja auch über Adobe abgelästert, oder?
Hat er.
Dass die faul seien.
Ja, und dass sie früher mal ganz toll waren. Aber die Diskussion hatten wir im Prinzip auch schon.
Ja, die hatten wir schon.
Ich denke, dass er das genauso sieht. Er bezeichnet Flash als Old Technology. Und da hat er einfach recht.
Ein bisschen was ist mir natürlich auch, gerade als wir das vorhin erzählten, da hab ich es nicht erwähnt, aber hier passt es eigentlich ganz gut rein, diese ganze DRM-Diskussion mit Streaming und so weiter und so fort. Also sozusagen, wer kann Streaming Content liefern? Im Augenblick ist das nur Flash. Wer ist es noch außer Flash? Potenziell Apple. Apple hat ein DRM-System, sie haben gute Geschäftskontakte zu den Fernsehanbietern, zu den Inhalteanbietern. Und Apple hat somit durchaus ein Interesse daran, dass ein weiteres DRM-System nicht aufs iPhone draufkommt, beziehungsweise nicht die guten Karten hat, wie iTunes mit dem Store im Augenblick hat.
Ich bin mir nicht... Also I'm not aware of it. Ich hab das DRM im Kontext Streaming bei Apple noch nicht gesehen. Das müsste ja dann in iTunes oder ins iPhone gehen. Das sind die einzigen Orte, wo sie ein DRM entforcen könnten. Ja, aber da weiß ich nichts von.
Oder noch als Browser-Plugin.
Du maßt Moves.
Na ja, ich meine, live Content, also DRM-geschützten, aufgezeichneten Content kannst du im Augenblick auch noch mit Flash oder mit iTunes machen.
Ja, aber das ist doch was anderes. Wenn du sagst, Flash, Streaming und DRM könnte Apple machen, klar könnten sie das tun, aber siehst du, bleib mal Butterweifische, siehst du das? Hast du da irgendeine Ankündigung gesehen? Ich weiß von nichts.
Nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht. Aber auch den Content aufgezeichnet und DRM kann im Augenblick auch nur im Wesentlichen Flash und iTunes, zumindest auf dem Mac.
Gut, jetzt waren wir bei dieser Diskussion schon. Jetzt hatten wir irgendwie Apple und Google. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal den Player, der sich in letzter Zeit ein bisschen die Muskeln hat spielen lassen, Bing nochmal mit aufnehmen. Wir sind ja gerade ganz gut in der Diskussion.
Habt ihr dieses TED-Video gesehen? Was?
Ich hab dieses TED-Video gesehen. Also es gab so eine... TED sagt dir was? TED ist so eine Präsentationsveranstaltung, wo immer Leute geladen werden, die schon ganz ordentlich was drauf haben und die dann halt in einem 5-10 Minuten, keine Ahnung, das ist eine exklusive Geschichte, wo aber wirklich kluge Leute kluge Sachen erzählen. Und diese TED-Sachen sollte man sich mal angucken. Da ist richtig viel zu holen.
Einige davon sind richtig inspirierend.
Also wirklich sehr viel Future Stuff.
Ist das einfach so eine TED oder was?
Ich glaube, das wissen jetzt mehr Hörer als du. Tatsache ist, es gab einen Vortrag von einem Menschen, der schon länger bei Microsoft arbeitet, der jetzt im Big Maps Team ist. Ich hab jetzt vergessen, auch so ein südamerikanischer Name. Auf jeden Fall hat er ein paar Features, die sie jetzt in Big Maps eingebaut haben. War das Beta? War das irgendwie jetzt schon? Läuft das schon? Keine Ahnung. Das war bestimmt wieder so eine Ankündigung, vermute ich mal. Und was sie halt gezeigt haben, war erstmal, dass Big Maps irgendwie im Detail ein paar Features hat, die Google Maps derzeit noch nicht hat. Das zoomt irgendwie schicker und so weiter. Und dann haben sie auch ein Feature gezeigt, wo sie Bilder von Flickr und anderen Quellen sich holen und nicht nur die GPS-Koordinate auswerten, wo das ist, sondern ihre Photomatching-Technologie und der Typ, der diese Demo gemacht hat. Der ist einer der Hauptentwickler von dieser Photosynth-Geschichte, was ein Forschungsprojekt bei Microsoft war.
Diese total geile Technologie.
Genau, diese total geile Technologie, wo sie so Bilder in 3D-Räume gemacht haben. Also sie konnten sozusagen komplette 3D-Räume erstellen aus Fotos. Und das haben sie jetzt im Prinzip auf Bing Maps angewendet. Das heißt, sie können einfach in real life geschossene Fotos in quasi ihre Variante von Street View mit einbauen. Das heißt, du siehst halt genau wie bei Street View so 3D-Modell. Und sie bauen auch die Häuser, die 3D-Modelle, damit rein. Also in diesem Street View, ich weiß nicht, wie heißt denn das bei Bing Maps? Keine Ahnung. Es hat, glaube ich, gar keinen Namen. Auf jeden Fall wisst ihr, was ich meine. Der Blick quasi um dich herum, als wärst du da, berücksichtigt einerseits schon 3D-Modelle, die sie haben. Das heißt, wenn du da auf ein Haus guckst, dann guckst du tatsächlich auch schon auf eine 3D-Fläche damit, sodass sie das auch noch mit berücksichtigen können. Und sie, was noch viel wichtiger ist, platzieren halt die Bilder dann korrekt an der richtigen Stelle. Und das machen sie auf Basis von Bildvergleich, was bestimmt eine Weile dauert. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt nur das mit Bildern machen können, wo auch die Brennweite und eine Kompassinformation mit drin ist. Sondern sie machen das halt irgendwie anders. Wie groß der manuelle Aufwand da ist, keine Ahnung.
Also ich hab mal so Modelle gesehen von diesen Fotosynths, wo sie komplett die Innenstadt von Prag nur aus Touristenaufnahmen zusammengestellt haben. Also ich glaube schon, dass das ein weitgehend automatisierter Prozess ist, ansonsten.
Kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Das sah auf jeden Fall ganz beeindruckend aus. Und dann hatten sie nochmal so eine Sonderdemo, wo sie dann wirklich live irgendwo hingeschaltet haben und quasi auch in diesen Streetview auch noch ein Live-Video reingemapped haben. Was dann eben sozusagen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, die Kamera hat dann geschwenkt. Und an dem Inhalt des geschwenkten Videos haben sie dann live auch das Bild dann sozusagen positioniert. Also so eine Art Realtime-Umgebungsmatching. Aber das war, das kann auch echt mega gefaked gewesen sein. Das war schwer abzulesen.
Also ich hab mir dieses Video angeguckt, hab das an der Bahn geguckt, bin im Büro angekommen, hab gedacht, okay, jetzt probier ich jetzt auf der Stelle aus. In meinem Chrome hab ich dann eingegeben Maps, hab ich gesucht nach Bing Maps und hab das aufgerufen und hab so eine Map gesehen, die soweit ganz okay ist und hab dann oben den 3D-Button gesehen und hab auf den 3D-Button geklickt.
Und dann kam, dieser Browser wird nicht unterstützt.
Dieser Browser unterstützt. Bitte nutzen Sie die Hilfe, um nachzugucken, welche Browser wir unterstützen.
Das hab ich auch gemacht.
Das ist so typisch Microsoft.
Und hast du es versucht nachzuschlagen?
Dann hab ich es versucht nachzuschlagen. Das ging nicht. Ich hab eine Hilfe gefunden, aber es gab keinerlei Hinweise.
Das war so voll eine Microsoft-Experience. Warum sagt das mir nicht gleich?
Erstens sagst du mir gleich. Zweitens sag, sag doch einfach, du bist ein Mac-User, für dich haben wir es nicht.
Oder sag mir zumindest, wo die Hilfe ist.
Sag mir, wo die Hilfe ist und schreib es in die Hilfe rein.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Oder pack ein Link auf die Hilfe oder irgendwas.
Also es läuft wahrscheinlich nur mit Internet Explorer unter Windows.
Nein, es läuft nicht nur mit Internet, es läuft auch unter Windows. Es läuft auch mit Firefox unter Windows. Und ich hab das auf dem Windows-PC nochmal aufgemacht. Dann muss er ein Programm installieren, dann lädt sich das Programm runter, installiert das Programm und dann muss er mit dem Firefox-Browser neu starten. Dann hab ich das mit dem Internet Explorer gemacht und ist mit dem Internet Explorer abgestürzt.
Also ich denke auch, das ist noch sehr beta. Und was es davon wirklich End-User verwertbar schafft, weiß ich nicht.
Und mit diesen eingebetteten Fotos, das haben sie auch. Das ist natürlich nicht so, dass man Tausende von Fotos hat, sondern im Wesentlichen haben sie erst mal ihre Luftaufnahmen reingepackt, was das Ganze total nervig macht. Weil sobald du irgendwo auf die Fläche eines Fotos klickst, denkst du, ah, du wolltest auf das Foto. Dann bist du schon unten und willst jetzt quasi 5 Meter weiter nach links gehen. Und klickst dann 5 Meter weiter nach links, wo natürlich, das sind ja alles Luftaufnahmen, auch eine Aufnahme drin ist. Dann zoomt der dich wieder raus, damit du wieder das gesamte Foto siehst. Das war total, also es ist wirklich so...
Also alles noch nicht so wirklich fertig.
Bei Google Maps hab ich damals gedacht, wow, geil. Und das ist heute ein Tool, was ich jeden Tag benutze. Bei Bing Maps hab ich mir gedacht, wow, geile Idee. Aber ihr hättet es mal vernünftig machen sollen.
Ich finde, was davon jetzt wirklich verwendbar ist, und nicht das einmal dahingestellt, ich finde zwei Sachen bemerkenswert an dieser ganzen Bing-Geschichte. Erstens, Microsoft investiert offensichtlich sehr viele Ressourcen. Ich trau dem Beraten noch nicht so richtig, aber es macht ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob diese Bing-Sparte so viel Eigenständigkeit gerade genießt, dass die vielleicht tatsächlich sogar mal was Benutzbares hinkriegen können, was mit Google konkurriert. Das wär ja mal was Neues. Aber wie gesagt, das kann ich nicht einschätzen und ich rechne auch jederzeit damit, dass wenn das irgendwie eine gewisse Traktion hat, ob es die erreichen wird, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber selbst wenn es dahin kommen würde, wäre ich auch nicht überrascht, wenn dann der Microsoft Moloch mit seiner ganzen Bürokratie das Ganze wieder auffrisst. Die zweite Sache, die ich bemerkenswert finde, daran ist, dass wir die ganze Zeit nur von Bing reden. Aber nicht von Microsoft. Dieses ganze Ding mit der Suchmaschine und mit den Maps, das ist so nicht Microsoft gebrennt, sondern das ist Bing. Und das findet auch schon Benutzung so, dass sie sich da auch versuchen, von ihrer eigenen schlechten Image abzukoppeln.
Das haben sie durchaus auch bei der Xbox zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, die ist ja auch nicht Microsoft gebrennt. Steht da irgendwo groß Microsoft drauf? Das ist die Xbox 360.
Aber das ist Hardware und das ist eine Gaming-Konsole. Und das ist schon nochmal auch was anderes. Dass sie das da auch nicht gemacht haben, kann ich sehen. Aber da war ja auch klar, dass der Name Microsoft in dem Markt sowieso für noch gar nichts stand. Während sie aber jetzt im Internet schon auch vieles mit Microsoft, also sie haben ihre ganzen Live-Geschichten und so weiter. Das ist ja mit Microsoft dann auch verheiratet. Mit dem Namen mein ich jetzt, mit Office und so weiter. Während das halt jetzt bei der Suche nicht so ist. Sie hätten es ja auch Microsoft Search nennen können.
Irgendjemand war da schlau genug, das sein zu lassen. Wollen wir an der Stelle mal, also ich glaube, es ist jetzt eigentlich super passend, über das andere Microsoft-Produkt neu, was ein bisschen aufgewirbelt hat zu reden, oder?
Ein anderes Microsoft-Produkt.
Das ist dieses Windows Phone 7. Womit Tims Standpunkt schon mal klar wird.
Ja, wann soll es rauskommen? Okay, also kommt es irgendwie 2011 irgendwann raus.
Also ich fand, was ich daran...
Also letztes Jahr war es doch so, dass sie 6 so schnell rausgebracht haben, weil es für 7 noch zu lange gedauert hätte. Genau, deswegen haben sie einen 6.5 rausgebracht.
Genau. Ja, weil sie halt eingesehen haben, dass sie gegen die Wand laufen. Deswegen benennen sie das jetzt um in Classic. Windows Phone Classic. Das ist dann ihr Name für die 6er-Reihe. Und sie versuchen jetzt mit dieser 7er-Reihe irgendwie komplett was Neues. Einen die Illusion zu geben, es sei irgendwas Neues.
Na ja, das ist... Sagen wir mal so.
Was? Ist da ein neuer Kernel drunter?
Ich weiß nicht, was da für ein neuer Kernel drunter ist, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall einen Ansatz gewählt, den man so bisher noch nicht kannte. Das ganze User-Interface?
Ja, was? Dass ich das alte komplett wegschmeißen muss?
Das ist das alte, aber es ist nicht...
Das User-Interface waren jetzt irgendwie 8 Kästchen. Hab ich da gesehen.
Nee, das ist... Nee, nee, nee. Das ist... Also ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, wie es in der Praxis funktioniert. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auf der einen Seite total geil ist. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass man es nach 2 Tagen an die Wand wirft. Aber dieser Gedanke, dass man hat ein paar Lebensbereiche sozusagen, also z.B. persönliche Kontakte, wo man dann die SMS-Nachrichten sieht und Telefonennachrichten sieht.
Auch diese Personal Hubs, oder wie die da hießen.
Wo man aber auch Facebook-Nachrichten sehen kann. Und dann ist das quasi so eine relativ große Fläche, mit der man horizontal durchscrollen kann. Und am Anfang sehe ich eine Übersicht, welche SMS-Nachrichten sind neu, welche das und das sind neu, mit wem hab ich als letztes telefoniert, wer hat mir als letztes eine Mail geschickt. Und dann kann ich so durchscrollen und kann mir angucken, das Ganze im Detail. Das Gleiche haben sie für Videos und für Office und für noch irgendeinen Bereich, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Ach so, Gaming, Xbox gemacht. Und das machte so einen ganz fliegen Eindruck, fand ich.
In der Demo, ein Jahr bevor es released werden soll.
Sie hatten ja auch Geräte da und die Leute haben ja auch an den Geräten rumgespielt und da scheint es auch schon so halbwegs funktionieren zu haben. Was ich aber sagen möchte ist...
Ja, aber in einem Jahr ist das auch schon wieder komplett veraltet.
Ja, aber was sie definitiv verstanden haben, sie haben definitiv verstanden, wir dürfen nicht noch so ein Ding wie Apple machen. Wir dürfen nicht einfach Apple kopieren, sondern sie haben sich Gedanken gemacht um einen komplett eigenen Ansatz und haben den dann auch sehr konsequent gefahren. Also es ist wirklich... Es ist nicht so wie so Glossy und Button und Candy-like wie bei Apple, sondern es sind flache Flächen, die eckig sind, mit Typo, kein Wert auf Eigens, auf tolle Bilder wertgelegt.
Soll es nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen sein wie der Sion?
Ja, ist es ja auch. Der Sion ist ja auch sehr textlastig.
Wo sie irgendwie immer so zwei Drittel des Bildschirms für irgendwie Schnickes opfern. Und dann stehen da so fünf Wörter.
Das ist schon alles... Also es ist alles große Schrift und so was. Ich sag auch nicht, dass es der letzte Wörter ist.
Sie bringen uns also jetzt ein Telefon von den Leuten, die dir den Sion brachten.
Ja, aber der Sion ist jetzt nicht der nächste große Fehler, weil er... Was? Weil das Gerät an sich scheiße wäre. Ich glaube, das Gerät an sich ist ganz okay.
Was macht denn das Gerät an sich aus?
Ein Telefon oder ein Player?
Hast du schon mal einen gehabt? Das gibt es gar nicht in anderen Ländern als in den USA. Das ist ein Gerät, das es noch nicht mal über seinen Heimmarkt hinaus geschafft hat. Das ist ein Fail, Mann.
Den Sonnen gibt es nicht in Deutschland? Ich hab nie behauptet, dass das Ding ein Erfolg wäre. Ich hab gesagt, es ist kein Fail, weil das Gerät an sich scheiße ist, sondern weil es einfach viel zu spät kam.
Also kein Fail wäre für Microsoft schon mal ein echter Erfolg. Ich denke, dass sie eigentlich kaum etwas anderes produzieren als Fail. Von daher ist es so.
Naja, ich geh dir jetzt mal her. Ja, nee, ich hab nie behauptet, hab ich irgendwann behauptet, dass das Ding ein Erfolg wäre?
Nein, du hast gesagt, er ist kein Fail. Das wäre aber schon ein Erfolg.
Ich hab gesagt, es ist keine schlechte Hardware. Und keine schlechte Software. Das wollte ich damit sagen. Ich hab, was ich auf Videos gesehen habe... Ja, hab ich auf Videos gesehen. Ich bitte dich. Erlaube ich mir das Urteil, dass das kein Totalversagen sei?
Was ich nicht in der Hand gehabt habe, will ich jetzt irgendwie nicht bewerten, ob es was taugt oder nicht. Ich sehe einfach nur, dass dieses Ding einfach keinen nennenswerten Erfolg hat. Und diesen nicht vorhandenen Erfolg, den übertragen sie jetzt aufs Telefon. Hurra, ich bin excited.
Sie haben einen eigenen Ansatz. Der unterscheidet sich von Apple. Ich glaube, niemand hat damit gerechnet, dass sie es tatsächlich schaffen, ein Gegenmodell zum iPhone auf die Beine zu stellen. Also nicht nur einfach irgendwie machen, die sind genau so wie Apple.
Ich rechne da auch nach wie vor nicht damit, dass sie das schaffen.
Ob sie das im Endeffekt hinkriegen, ist eine große Frage.
Ich bitte dich, das ist jetzt noch ein Jahr hin. Bis dahin haben sie vielleicht bestenfalls noch 15% dieses Marktes. Weniger weltweit. 10% vielleicht. Das ist das, was ihnen noch bleibt. Und das wird dann auch erstmal nicht besser werden. Die müssen überhaupt erstmal jemanden finden, der bereit ist, mit ihrem OS ein Telefon zu bauen. Warum sollte man denn mit Microsoft gehen? Bitte schön.
Weil das alle machen.
Nee, alle machen jetzt Android. Das ist das, was sich auf dieser Microsoft-Messer auch abgezeichnet hat.
Weil sie haben nämlich ein richtig dickes, gutes Ding haben sie in der Hinterhand. Und das ist Microsoft Office. Das ist natürlich so. Und zwar für die ganzen...
Auf dem Mobiltelefon?
Nee. Und zwar Exchange. Du kannst vernünftig Mails darauf lesen. Du hast richtig dieses ganze Sharepoint-Zeug und weißt ja toll, wo es alles heißt, was ich alles auch nicht kenne.
Ich bitte dich, ein Phone-Summer-Phone.
Wieso, das kannst du... Mann, das iPhone wird nun sowohl, also ich meine, es wird in Firmen eingesetzt, massenhaft. Warum wird es in Firmen eingesetzt? Weil du hast auf der einen Seite ein geiles Telefon, wo du tolle Apps drauf installieren kannst, du kannst aber auch dein ganzen Exchange-Zeug jetzt mittlerweile da draufbringen.
Ja, das ist sogar das einzige Telefon, was derzeit die Exchange fordert.
Na ja, bei Android gibt es das bei vielen auch.
Kein Android-Phone, was Verschlüsselungen macht.
Okay, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Nun wird das aber so sein, dass die Integration von Mail in dieses Gerät ist wesentlich besser. Also zumindest in diesem Exchange. Weil sie klein gezeigt haben und sich alle gesehen haben.
Sie haben ein Video gezeigt.
Sie haben nicht nur ein Video gezeigt, sie haben Prototypen gezeigt.
Ein Jahr! Ich glaub denen doch nichts. Ein Jahr! Ich bitte dich. Da haben Leute an den Prototypen gesessen. Ja, Prototypen. Worüber reden wir? Wie viel Zeit wollen wir in diesem Podcast auf einen Prototypen von Microsoft verwenden? Ich bitte dich. Diese Firma hat mehrfach gezeigt, dass sie nicht in der Lage ist, Sachen, die sie angekündigt haben, auch nur binnen Jahresfrist zu liefern. Was ist denn hier mit dieser bekloppten Steuerung von ihren komischen Xbox-Spiele, was sie vor einem Jahr angekündigt haben? Nichts. Wo es irgendwie die nächste Generation... Also jede angekündigte Version kommt später.
Das war deren typische Strategie, wenn eine Konkurrenz irgendwas bringt, dass sie auch irgendwas ankönnen, damit gar keiner auf die Konkurrenz losgeht und dann kommt von Microsoft aber auch nichts.
Lass uns das bitte mit folgender Sache beenden. Microsoft hat was angekündigt. Nicht durcheinander. Microsoft hat was angekündigt, wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis. Sie sagen, in einem Jahr kommt es. Ich würde sagen, wenn es dann kommt, reden wir nochmal drüber. Bis dahin ist das alles bogus. Das, was jetzt stattfindet, was man auch gesehen hat, in Barcelona, wenn man da war, ich war natürlich nicht da, aber das, was die Berichte machen, nahezu jeder Hersteller macht ein Android-Phone. Ob die damit Erfolg haben, ist eine andere Sache, aber es ist nicht so, dass nahezu jeder Hersteller angekündigt hat, dass sie jetzt mit Windows-Mobile irgendwie voranschreiten wollen. Wie doch? Es gibt nur einen einzigen Hersteller, der überhaupt noch Windows-Mobile macht.
Wir können...
Die haben auch gerade das letzte Android ungefähr auf Android nachgeschaut.
Aber natürlich setzen die auch auf Android, aber es hat quasi... Microsoft hat eine große Latte, nun weiß man natürlich nicht, wie viele davon wirklich geredet.
Microsoft hat eine große Latte?
An Produkten.
Es ist die Frage, wie viele von den Herstellern das nachher auch tatsächlich ein Gerät produzieren. Aber Gerätehersteller, die gesagt haben, ja, wir wollen so ein Windows-7-Phone produzieren, gibt es einige. Und das ist neben HTC ist das, ich glaube auch noch Sony Ericsson, das sind wirklich diverse Hersteller, große Hersteller, die gesagt haben, wir werden ein Gerät mit diesem Betriebssystem drauf produzieren.
Ich warte ab, bis das passiert. Sony Ericsson wird es wahrscheinlich dann schon gar nicht mehr geben, wenn das irgendwie rauskommt.
Ja, ich sage ja nicht, dass Sony Ericsson jetzt toll da steht und Nokia ist auch Kleid und außer Apple hat eh keine Überlebenschancen. Tim ist mir klar. Aber was Microsoft auf jeden Fall auf den Tisch gelegt hat, sind ein paar Ideen. Und das muss man Ihnen, finde ich, kann man anrechnen.
Okay, wir fassen zusammen. Microsoft hat mal wieder eine Idee. Hurra, ich werde noch ein Feuerwerk beantragen. Nächstes Thema. Ja? Wir reden nicht über Nokia, oder? Wir reden nicht über Nokia. Nein, bitte nicht.
Doch, wir müssen über Nokia reden.
Auf der Liste steht doch jetzt was anderes.
Ja, aber jetzt sind wir gerade beim Mobiltelefonen. Jetzt wollen wir doch nicht wieder was ganz anderes... Also ganz kurz.
Den Punkt von da unten, ja?
Ja, genau, dieses Migo. Es ist so eine geile, epische Saga, was sie da irgendwie abziehen mit ihrer US-Strategie. Nachdem, als sie jetzt, glaube ich, in den letzten Wochen kurzfristig auch Symbian wieder ein ganz heißes Eisen war, haben sie jetzt ihr neues Super-Rennpferd Maemo auch wieder eingeschampft.
Was?
Ja, also...
Die Produkte kommen und gehen ja schneller als...
Moment, sie haben es nicht komplett eingeschampft, sondern sie haben jetzt angekündigt, dass sie...
Sie haben es aufgewertet, komm, sie haben es aufgewertet.
Sie gehen mit einem anderen Experten im Mobiltelefonbereich zusammen, nämlich Intel, das sie auch noch keiner auf der Liste hatte.
Nutzen aber nicht die Intel-Chips, oder wie war das?
Na ja, es ist vollkommen unklar.
Was nutzt sie denn überhaupt mit denen?
Intel hat auf jeden Fall irgendwas gestartet, das hieß Moblin. Und das war sozusagen ihre Vision für ein OS, so nach dem Motto, wolltet nicht bitte, bitte mal auch unsere Chips benutzen und nicht immer nur Arm? So, und wir haben auch ein OS dafür. Keine Ahnung.
Es ist nur ein OS, aber die Chips sind nicht ihr OS. Hab ich doch erst was gelesen, dass Nokia und Intel zusammenarbeiten, also Beheisestand ist, glaube ich, aber dass Nokia trotzdem nicht die Intel-Chips nimmt.
Genau, hier geht es jetzt erstmal um Software. Also, Intel hat ein OS... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das existiert oder ob das auch nur so eine vage Idee ist. Auf jeden Fall läuft das unter dem Namen Moblin.
Man kann theoretisch irgendwas runterladen.
Und sie haben jetzt angekündigt, Nokia und Intel bauen sozusagen wieder so einen Loserclub auf und führen diese OSs zusammen. Und dann heißt das MeeGo. M-E-E-G-O.
Das wird bestimmt heißen, wie viel ich laufe.
Großes Ding irgendwie. Jetzt haben die Leute gerade mal angefangen, bei Naemo auch nur am Ansatz nachzudenken, jetzt heißt das schon wieder anders. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Marketing-Fails, die sich jetzt noch erlauben wollen, aber es nimmt kein Ende.
Da brauchen wir eigentlich auch gar nicht so viel Zeit darüber verlieren, oder?
Nee, deswegen wollte ich das auch noch mal schnell hinterher machen.
Das sind jetzt erste Bilder von Nokia X10 mit dem neuen Symbian aufgetaucht, gerade eben. Also so FTC-Dokumente.
I'm so excited. I'm so fucking excited.
Symbian sollten sie wirklich mal langsam einstammen.
Okay, Smartphones, Ende, Schluss. Wollen wir uns jetzt über deine Magic-Maus unterhalten?
Können wir kurz machen. Ich hatte mir vorgestern so im Anschwarn von irgendwas, oder vor drei Tagen, eine Magic-Maus gekauft und hab sie gestern wieder zurückgegeben. So ein Scheißteil.
Erzähl mal.
Also erstmal hatte ich ständig Verbindungsabbrüche mit meinem Rechner. Die waren also so...
Okay, du spielst den Bad Cop, ich spiel jetzt mal den Good Cop. Dann machen wir gleich so keines.
Hast du auch eine Bluetooth-Tastatur?
Weil bei mir keine Verbindungsabbrüche.
Okay, du hast keine Verbindungsabbrüche.
Und ich hab zwei Stück. Eine auf Arbeit, eine zu Hause.
Und die kann ja nichts. Die hat ja echt keinerlei...
Doch, die kann scrollen.
Also man kann klicken, man kann rechts klicken, man kann scrollen und man hat so zwei Finger wischen nach links und nach rechts. Für im Browser zurück, im Browser nach rechts.
Das tut sich auch nie.
So, hier dieses Programme wechseln, Desktop anzeigen, in Exposé-Modus gehen, hat die alles nicht. Was ich auf meinem Trackpad ganz selbstverständlich habe, dass ich hier mal eben mit vier Fingern zwischen Programm hin und her wechseln kann, was ich jeden Tag ungefähr 5000 Mal benutze. Ja, ich dachte auch mal, wenn die dann Zusatzgerät für mein MacBook rausbringen, dass das mindestens das Gleiche bietet, was dieses Trackpad darin bietet.
Vielleicht kommt ja eine Erweiterung, dass du das Tablet oder das iPad neben deinem Laptop legen kannst und dann da deinen Riesentouch hast.
Das gibt es ja schon für iPhone als Applikation sowas.
Unten mir ist bei der Gelegenheit auch aufgefallen, dass ich Mäuse einfach mittlerweile total doof finde und nur noch Trackpads benutze. Mich nerven Mäuse, das finde ich furchtbar. Ich habe richtig mitgekriegt, wie meine Hand verkrampft.
Ja, das hatte ich auch. Das ist nach einer Woche weg.
Super, warum soll ich 70 Euro ausgeben für was, was nach einer Woche das Leiden weg ist?
Das ist nicht dein Leiden weg, sondern deine Verkrampftheit von vorher, die sich wieder entspannen muss.
Nein, das geht aus dem Trackpad jetzt viel, viel besser.
Also bei mir ist es so, wenn ich jetzt meine Maus von vorne nehme, die ist so eklig hoch, ist voll unangenehm.
Ich habe vorher keine Maus benutzt.
Die ist voll flach, das ist voll gut.
Ich habe vorher einfach keine Maus benutzt. Ich habe vorher ein Trackpad benutzt, damit hat sich der Salat.
Ich bin Mausschubster seit 86.
Also ich bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit meiner Magic Mouse. Ich habe allerdings ein generelles Problem damit. Und das ist, dass man doch sehr häufig bei der Benutzung mal eben so über die Oberfläche streicht und damit Scroll-Events auslöst, die man unter Umständen gar nicht haben will. Und das ist bei ein paar Sachen hochgradig nervig. Zum Beispiel im Quicktime-Player, du schaust ja irgendwie einen Film an. Du willst einfach nur deine Maus aus dem Weg schieben, um deine Tastatur ranzukommen. Oder du willst sie einfach aus dem Weg haben. Und dabei fährst du halt da drüber und dann bleibt halt sofort dein Film stehen. Oder noch schlimmer, du scrollst ihn dann noch 2 Minuten zurück. Das ist sehr nervig. Und auch Klickereien in Google Earth zum Beispiel werden irgendwie schnell vernichtet. Also wenn du zum Beispiel so Streetview einschaltest. Ja, du zooms so ein bisschen rum.
Man bräuchte einen Zoom an, damit man nicht mit einem Klick da reinkommt, wo man vorher war.
Du kannst also einfach keinen... Es ist nicht möglich, einen Doppelklick zu machen, zum Beispiel ohne dann auch noch so minimale Scrollanteile mit reinzubringen. Was dann bei Google Earth den Effekt hat, also wenn ich zum Beispiel diese Streetview-Bälle einschalte, womit du ja in Google Earth sozusagen direkt Streetview noch mit drin hast, und du willst dann in diese Streetview-Ball reinfliegen, also quasi da den richtigen Streetview-Modus enablen, dann musst du halt doppelklicken. Aber wenn du halt nur noch ein bisschen rumscrollst, während er das anfliegt, weil er muss da, kannst du nicht sofort machen, nein, er muss da reinfliegen, und wenn du halt während dieses Fluges da irgendwie auch nur minimal scrollst, dann bricht das sofort wieder ab. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass es überhaupt nicht möglich ist, mit dieser Maus das zu benutzen. Kann man jetzt auch sagen, okay, da könnte Google auch nochmal am User-Interface ein bisschen werkeln, aber das gilt auch genauso gut für den Quicktime Player, aber es ist irgendwie, müssen sie glaube ich diese Maus-Software noch aktualisieren, sodass wenn er sagt, okay, da ist jetzt Click, dass dann nicht auch noch kann Spuren von Scroll-Bewegungen enthalten mäßig.
Was ich habe, ich benutze hier das Xcode mit dem iPhone-Simulator. Und im iPhone-Simulator muss man ja auch mit der Maus touchen und dann so schieben und manchmal kommst du halt in Versuch, du willst halt scrollen mit der Magic-Maus. Dann blockt der iPhone-Simulator für so ein paar Sekunden, weil er irgendwie auf Events war oder so und das geht einfach nicht.
Ja, da ist irgendwie...
Aber trotzdem ist einfach das Scrollen an allen anderen Stellen, wo es funktioniert, ist einfach unersetzbar, finde ich. Das Scrollen von der Magic-Maus, das ist einfach auch dieses Nachlauf, wie heißt es hier? Dieser Nachlauf, der ist so smooth und so schick und schön und bequem und natürlich einfach vom Verhalten, das macht einfach viel mehr Spaß.
Das finde ich auch, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Verbesserung. Das Ding ist nicht ohne Probleme, aber es ist definitiv die beste Maus, die sie bisher hatten. Und vor allem...
Aber kriegt man jetzt schon welche?
Funktioniert sie einfach super auf weißen Tischen. Also die alte Maus hat ja hier überhaupt nicht auch nur einen Fünkien Bewegung gemacht und diese Maus funktioniert sagenhaft gut und die putzt auch ganz gut, sehe ich gerade hier.
Oh ja, die nimmt den Dreck ordentlich mit auf.
Ja, ich fand auch, also das muss ich auch sagen, so die ganze Verpackungs-Auge fand ich auch eher suboptimal das Erlebnis.
Verpackungs-Auge?
Nein, die war reingeklebt in die Verpackung.
Was du beschwerst dich jetzt darüber, wie dein Gerät verpackt war, jetzt bist du aber auch echt voll im Fanboy-Modus, oder?
Im Anti-Fanboy-Modus.
Anti-Fanboy-Modus.
Und die war reingeklebt?
Haben sie ja berichtet, dass dieser komische Klebestreif, wo auch Reste an der Unterseite der Maus kleben bleiben, das haben sie noch nicht geändert. Das geht aber wirklich nicht. Wobei, das ist nur am Anfang beim Auspacken so. Und da meine beiden Mäuse, die eine ist aus New York, die andere wurde mir aus San Francisco mitgebracht, hab ich die Verpackung nie gesehen.
Meine lag im Eimek bei, von der, weiß ich auch nicht, die Verpackung war.
Ich hab halt diesen Schneewittchen-Sack, den hat man jetzt auch hinreichend gesehen. Aber ich würde sagen, die Magic Mouse ist ein Produkt, das Steve niemals in der Hand gehabt hätte. Ansonsten wäre es so, die Apple Factories nicht verlassen dürfen.
Ich denke, das können sie noch fixen.
Das ist ein Software-Problem.
Das ist ein Software-Problem, definitiv.
Ja, mag sein, aber ich fand das Erlebnis eher nicht so toll.
Neues Thema, neues Glück.
Du musst mehr Geduld haben.
Ich will mich nicht über Opera und Mobile unterhalten.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber lass uns über diesen MPEG-4 kommen.
Opera und Mobile finde ich ganz schön.
Das ist ja schöner bei Smartphones.
Sind wir kurz bei Smartphones. Opera und Mobile, ich hoffe, das kommt aufs iPhone. Das hat zu Ende.
Aber eigentlich dürfte es ja gar nicht, weil es ja Doubled Functionalities ist.
Aber es gibt auch alternative Browser von anderen.
Diese Regeln vom Anfang. Also Apple ist ja schon ein bisschen entspannter geworden, oder? Wobei ich jetzt gerade gelesen hab, die haben jetzt ganzen Sex-Apps rausgeschmissen oder sowas.
Die sind nicht entspannter geworden, was Browser betrifft.
Na doch, es gibt alternative Browser mittlerweile.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie Opera und Mobile durchschieben will.
Ich hoffe, sie werden es durchschieben.
Du kannst es vielleicht hoffen. Ich rechne da aber nicht mit, weil es schlicht und ergreifend dazu führen wird, dass du Webseiten, die interaktiv sind, nicht benutzen kannst. Das wird Apple einfach nicht erlauben.
Ich finde, sie sollten es erlauben. Ich glaube, die tun es auch, weil inzwischen ist das Ding, glaube ich, egal.
Es wird wahrscheinlich eh keiner benutzen. Von daher ist es mir dann auch egal, wenn sie es machen.
Doch, wenn man eine langsame Internetverbindung hat, dann ist es viel, viel besser. Dann ist es einfach deutlich schneller als mit, als ein echter Webbrowser.
Ich weiß nicht, ich will meine Webseiten nicht in Skandinavien erinnern lassen. Das ist ja echt das Privacy-Problem.
Stimmt, das war diese Methode, ne?
Die erinnern für dich halt in Skandinavien.
Die erinnern für dich aus irgendwelchen Zwergern, klar.
Ich will nicht meine Webseiten woanders erinnern lassen.
Noch eine Frage zu dem Ding. Kostet das eigentlich was? Würde das was kosten, das Opera-Mobile?
Also das ist auf allen ihren anderen... Also Opera-Mini und an denen orientiert es sich sehr. Wenn es Opera-Mobile ist, hat es im Allgemeinen Geld gekostet. Das rendert aber lokal. Aber ich glaube, das ist eher so Opera-Mini mit diesen Rendern außerhalb. Dadurch werden sie so unglaublich schnell und können das machen. Und das hat nie was gekostet. Das hat auf den anderen Telefonen, auf denen man es haben kann, nie was gekostet. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es bei...
Aber es ist interessant, dass man Webseiten, die eigentlich als HTML, als Text und very compressible stuff irgendwie ankommen, dass man die als Bild erinnert und das dann schneller gehen soll.
Nee, sie erinnern es ja nicht als Bild. Sie wandeln es um in ein anderes Format. Also Text ist ja schon drin. Aber zum Beispiel erinnern sie... Ich glaube sie komprimieren es erstens nochmal richtig schön. Und zweitens werden Bilder runtergerechnet. Also JavaScript geht dann schon noch, oder was? Also bei... Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was sie auf ein iPhone dann hinkriegen. Also sie haben für Android Opera Mobile vorgestellt. Der kommt komplett JavaScript. Opera Mini auf diesen ganzen Kleingeräten kann ein bisschen JavaScript. Und...
Müssen wir uns noch weiter über so einen Randgruppenthema? Ich meine, dieses Tool hat keinerlei Bedeutung. Es ist nur, dass Opera die ganze Zeit versucht Aufmerksamkeit dadurch zu erheischen, indem sie die ganze Zeit ankündigen, dass sie das ja jetzt releasen wollen würden. Aber dann, wenn man mal nachfragt, so ein Ja, nie, aber wir haben es ja noch nicht wirklich eingereicht und wir trauen uns nicht und wir haben Angst. Wir wollen, dass da irgendwie so ein Aufschweiß durch Netz geht, dass irgendwie alle Apple verdammen.
Dass das Opera-Mini jetzt irgendwie keine Bedeutung hätte, ist ja nun auch mal eine alberne Behauptung.
Ja, wo hat das eine Bedeutung?
Ich glaube, das sind 50 Millionen User. Bist du sicher?
50 Millionen User, was heißt das? Die das als ihren Default-Browser auf ihren iPhones benutzen, wo es nicht verfügbar ist?
iPhones auf ihren anderen Telefonen.
Glaube ich auch nicht. Und selbst wenn. Ja, du hast wieder Zahlen, die du nicht belegen kannst, Max.
Doch, hier haben wir eine Presseerklärung von Oprah.
Jetzt reden wir schon ganz lange über dieses Thema. Ich will aber was wichtiges reden.
In June 2009, 26,5 Millionen Unique Consumers.
Installierte Einheiten, weil mitgeliefert.
Das wird nicht mitgeliefert. Außerdem sind es Users. Die messen ja dadurch, dass sie das alles durch ihren Proxy durchscheuchen können. Sagen die wirklich, wir hatten in Juni 26 Millionen Unique Consumers. Sie hatten 10 Milliarden Pageviews innerhalb eines Monats in Juni letzten Jahres.
Okay, ich kann das gerade nicht mit anderen Zahlen in Verbindung bringen, ehrlich zu sein.
Das sind, die haben schon viele User.
Findet der Chat das Thema jetzt noch spannend?
Achso, und hier sind die SDS-erreichenden 50 Millionen User.
Wie unser Live-Sendungs-Delay ist. das findet keiner spannend. So, was ich spannend finde, ist die Sache mit dem MPEG-4-Lizenz-Klimbim. Hätte eigentlich super vorhin noch zu unserer HTML5-Diskussion gepasst. Aber, haben wir jetzt zum falschen Zeitpunkt gebracht. Ihr wisst das? Sagt euch das was? MPEG-4-LA? Das ist die Bude, die die Verwaltung des MPEG-4-Patentpools übernimmt. Also das ist sozusagen die Bude, wo man sich eine Lizenz holt und die die Aussagen darüber trifft, wie denn die Lizenzierung von MPEG-4-Standards läuft. Und das ist ja nun so, wie bei allen anderen größeren Industrieprojekten, wo viel sogenanntes intellectual property zusammenkommt und vor allem viele Patente zusammenkommen, die die Firmen eben halten, dafür, dass man eben ein Industriestandard macht und dass diese Firmen quasi Sachen, auf die sie eben Patente halten und wo sie ja dann theoretisch eben auch ein Anrecht auf Royalties hätten, je nachdem wie ihre eigenen Ansprüche da eben sind, dass sie das eben in einen Pool reinschmeißen und dass eben ein Pool-Verwaltungsorganisation dann dritten gegenüber bestimmte Deals anbietet, wie sie eben diesen ganzen Sack auf einmal nutzen können. Und auf der Basis funktioniert diese ganze MPEG-4 Geschichte. Da ist Audio drin, da ist Video drin, da ist Video vor allem in verschiedenen Profilen drin. Sprich, es gibt einen Royalty-Free-Bereich oder zumindest macht es so den Eindruck, dass der Royalty-Free wäre, dass es dieses Baseline-Profile, das ist sozusagen MPEG-4 Audio und Video, wobei das Video eben nur und das Audio auch nur, sagen wir mal, in seiner Mindestqualität mit drin ist. Das heißt, du hast da AAC für Audio, aber du hast eben nicht irgendwie AAC, H2, diese Advanced-Variante, die es davon ja auch noch gibt. Und du hast H264, aber du hast eben dann dieses Baseline-Profile, was eben bestimmte mögliche Features von H264 ausschließt und wenn du dann eben auf Main-Profile gehst und ich glaube, es gibt da noch ein Advanced-Profile, dann hast du halt immer mehr, sodass wenn du eben so richtig die maximale Bildqualität mit der maximalen Kompression, mit der minimalen Latenz haben willst, dass du eben gegebenenfalls dann für deine Werkzeuge, die du erstellst, also deine Software, deine Hardware-Geräte oder was auch immer du da eben verkaufst und anbietest und das Volk bringen möchtest, Lizenzzahlungen zu leisten hast. Und das machst du eben mit der LA. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass diese MPEG-4-Lizenzbestimmungen auch vorsagen, ab Anfang 2011, also Anfang nächsten Jahres, Lizenzen einzufordern von Leuten, die Content-Anbieter sind. Und das ist eigentlich schon immer so eine Sache gewesen. Es ist ja schon mehrfach klar geworden, dass ich eigentlich durchaus ein Verfechter der Idee, MPEG-4 zu benutzen bin, aber muss sagen, das ist auch das, wo mir selber auch immer wieder so ein bisschen schlecht wurde, weil einfach das ja auch bedeuten könnte, dass man ja auch als Podcast-Anbieter unter Umständen gezwungen ist, einfach nochmal Lizenzzahlungen zu leisten, um seinen eigenen Content zu machen. Jetzt steh ich da. Und die eigentliche Nachricht, die das Ganze jetzt auf den Tisch wirft, ist die Ankündigung der MPEG-4 LA, dass sie das aussetzen und um weitere fünf Jahre erstmal verschieben. Dieser Patentpol läuft ja auch irgendwann aus, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann.
Hättest du auf OK-Forbes gesetzt.
Ja, hätte ich mal auf OK-Forbes gesetzt, beziehungsweise ist es dann immer noch möglich, seine Formate zu ändern, wenn das dann wirklich mal ein Problem wird.
Aber mal ehrlich, in einem Audio-Podcast, in fünf Jahren, habe ich so viel Bandbreite, dann kannst du von mir aus, ich weiß nicht, ob der Apple loslässt, ob die auch gebühren wollen, aber von mir aus kannst du fast in CD-Qualität unkomprimiert rausjagen. Das wäre mir so wurscht, weil da wirst du so viel Bandbreite haben in fünf Jahren. Bei einem Empfang vielleicht.
Beim Empfang, aber doch nicht beim Senden.
Das kostet Geld.
Aber Faktor 10 ist immer relevant.
Ja schon, aber fünf Jahre ist auch echt eine lange Zeit.
Und Faktor 20 ist auch relevant. Wir reden eigentlich bei Audio und Video mit MPEG 4 eher so um Faktor 20. Und Faktor 20 ist immer teurer. Also das kannst du drehen, wie du willst. Beziehungsweise, wenn du in einem Maße sendest, wo das nicht durchschlägt auf deine Kosten nennenswert, bist du auch zu diesen Lizenzierungszahlungen nicht hergehalten.
Es gibt da so Minima.
Du musst für jede Datei jetzt auch noch Geld zahlen. Wenn du ein bestimmtes Volumen an Sachen raushaust, also unter einem gewissen Threshold, ist das sowieso nicht dein Thema. Aber wir wissen auch, Sachen, die populärer werden können. Auf einmal musst du eine komplett neue Rechnung machen für deinen ganzen Kram. Du zahlst nicht nur deine Infrastruktur und deine Bandbreite, sondern auch noch die Nutzungsrechte dieses Formats. Ich muss sagen, und ich habe jetzt keine guten Gründe dafür, warum ich das denke, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dieses Ding, was hier jetzt um fünf Jahre verschoben werden, wird auch in fünf Jahren nochmal verschoben werden. Damit kann ich auch falsch liegen. Das ist nur so ein bisschen mein Gefühl. Weil ich einfach glaube, dass ich der Gedanke langfristig durchsetzen wird, dass alle insgesamt mehr davon profitieren, wenn das einfach frei bleibt. Ob das allerdings jetzt die Patentholder auch genauso sehen und ob sich da innerhalb dieser LA ein entsprechender Kompromiss dann auch wirklich abzeichnen wird, das sei jetzt nochmal außen vor gelassen.
Interessant wäre, wie viel die denn einnehmen würden, falls sie jetzt schon anfangen würden zu kassieren. Gibt es da um Milliarden von Dollar oder sind das denn nur 50 Millionen oder was? Da wäre meine Zahl interessant. Eigentlich könnten sich dann so ein paar Firmen wie Microsoft, Google, Apple und alle die halt auch lauter so eine Codex irgendwie benutzen und verbreiten und Tools dafür stellen könnten, die ja einfach mal sagen, okay, wir legen dick zusammen, zahlen die aus, das Ding ist offen und dann ist endlich Ruhe hier im Karton.
Also, ich hab keine Quelle gerade, aber ich meine, mich zu erinnern, dass es Berichte gab, dass Apple einer der Gründe ist, warum die das verschoben haben. Apple war schon immer auf dem Standpunkt, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist. Nur waren sie damit halt auch erstmal nur einer von mehreren, die diese Meinung geäußert haben. Wer da noch auf diesem Standpunkt steht, weiß ich nicht so genau. Ich hab schon immer mal jemanden gesucht, der da in irgendeiner Form ein bisschen Einblick hat, was da eigentlich tatsächlich politisch so abgeht, hab ich aber bisher noch nicht gefunden. Das ist aber so ein bisschen meine Kenntnis. Jetzt ist halt die Frage, gibt es eine Alternative? Gibt es eine Alternative, mit dem Druck machen kann? Jetzt kann man sagen, ok, es gibt Teora. Firefox unterstützt nach wie vor nur Teora bisher. Und zwar genau aus diesen Gründen. Weil es eben einfach nicht lizenzfrei ist, beziehungsweise weil es auch generell mit ihrem Prinzip von offenen Lizenzen und dem Bundling von Software unter diesen Lizenzen einfach widerspricht. Und sie sagen halt einfach, wir können das nicht machen. Jetzt ist Teora ja, also wenn man sich nochmal diese Videogeschichte anschaut, gab es ja die Bude ON2, die haben einige gute Codecs erzeugt. Und einer davon war ja auch das, was heute Flash Video ausmacht. Beziehungsweise ihr VP6. Jetzt muss ich mich kurz zurücknehmen. Also das erste ist das minimale Flash Video Format. Das, also jetzt wirklich Video und nicht der Container. Basierte im Wesentlichen auf H263. Also einem frühen Vorläufer von H264, was so aus diesem Bildtelefonie-Standard-Kram heraus erwachsen ist. Und ich glaube, das war von Sorensen eine Entwicklung. Und dann hatten sie irgendwie, ab irgendwie Flash-Versionen habe ich vergessen, gab es auch noch den VP6 Codec, der auch noch fleißig verwendet wird. Der war von ON2. Und eine frühere Version, was ist das? VP2? Also irgendeine andere Entwicklung von ON2 wurde ja mal von ON2, dem XIF-Projekt sozusagen, gespendet. Und daraus ist dann Teora geworden. Also Teora ist auch quasi im Wesentlichen Technologie, die mal bei ON2 entwickelt wurde. Und diese Bude ON2 wurde jetzt von Google gekauft. Und was sie in ihrem Portfolio haben, ist eben ein weiterer Videokodik, den sie VP8 nennen. Und von dem sie behaupten, genauso wie sie das auch von Teora behaupten, dass, äh, das war mein Telefon, Entschuldigung, genauso wie sie von Teora behaupten, das wäre patentfrei, behaupten sie das auch von VP8. Diese Bude ist jetzt von Google gekauft worden. So, jetzt können wir alle mal ein bisschen in uns gehen und überlegen, was das bedeutet in dieser ganzen Konstellation. Ich vermute mal, Google steht da auf einer ähnlichen Position wie Apple, was so diese Formatfreiheit betrifft. Weil sie ja letzten Endes auch mit, sagen wir mal, mit ihren Lizenzen für Chrome OS und so weiter einfach ähnliche Probleme haben werden, wie Mozilla, vermute ich mal. Oder auch immer einfach keine Lust haben, da zu zahlen, weiß ich nicht. Warum kaufen sie jetzt diese Bude? Warum kauft Google sich den Videohersteller eines neuen Codex, der von sich behauptet, patentfrei zu sein und den sie ja theoretisch dann genauso wie Teora in The Wild releaseen könnten und dann auch, sagen wir mal, technisch mehr auf Augenhöhe zu sein mit H264? Ob das eine oder andere jetzt besser ist, kann ich nicht bewerten. Ich denke mal, für die meisten Leute macht es keinen großen Unterschied am Ende des Tages. Naja, ich denke nicht, dass das letzten Endes der Punkt ist. Nur weil da jetzt etwas ausgesetzt wurde, ist das Thema ja als solches nicht vom Tisch. Das ist ja nach wie vor so, dass bei H264 gibt es einfach immer noch dieses Bedrohungsszenario, dass man Geld zahlen muss für Content-Delivery. So oder so musst du aber auch Geld zahlen für Content-Erzeugung. Also Encoder, Kostengeld und es gibt ja auch absurde Limitierungen. Wenn man sich mal so die Lizenzbedingungen von Final Cut Pro anschaut, da gibt es dann tatsächlich Aussagen darüber, was du damit produzieren darfst und was nicht. Ich kriege das im Einzelnen jetzt nicht mehr zusammen. Das werde ich mir nicht genauer angeschaut. Aber es gibt da so Absurditäten. Und Absurditäten und Limitierungen, wie du irgendwas benutzen kannst und so weiter, da sind wir uns glaube ich einig, dass es hat einfach nicht zu sein im Internet. Und ich denke, dass es auch in Googles Interesse wäre, wenn es halt etwas gäbe, was einfach frei ist. Jetzt können sie aber nicht auch einfach nur VP8 nehmen, das Open-Sourcen, was weiß ich, oder irgendeine mega-freie Lizenz stellen, das auch noch dem XIF-Projekt verantworten oder vielleicht so ein eigenes Projekt wieder, so Google-Code-mäßig zu starten. Das können sie natürlich alles tun. Und dann könnten sie auch vielleicht binnen kürzester Zeit dafür sorgen, dass es entsprechende Plugins gibt und was weiß ich und freie Lizenzierung und Hardware, die man lizenzieren kann, nur wird das stattfinden. Kann Google zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch einen neuen Video-Codec auf den Markt werfen, der irgendeine nennenswerten Chance auf Erfolg hat, sich zu verbreiten? Ich hab da meine Zweifel. Also ich frag mich einfach, was deren Strategie ist an der Stelle. Ob die einfach die Bude nur gekauft haben, um einfach noch eine Keule mehr in der Hand zu haben und somit irgendwas Theoretischen zu wählen, um H264, also diesem ganzen Patentpool sozusagen zu sagen, Leute, wir wissen, dass wir derzeit da schlechter dastehen. Aber wenn ihr euch wirklich auch weiterhin quer stellt, einfach frei zu sein, zumindest für den End-User oder für den Content-User, für diejenigen, die einfach die Tools kaufen und dann Content erzeugen, dann werden wir alles in unserer Macht stehende dafür tun, um eine Alternative zu machen. Und dann werdet ihr sowieso noch weniger Patenteinnahmen haben.
Die wollen natürlich auch unabhängiger sein. Die haben ja nicht nur Flash, sondern auch QuickTime bieten sie an bei YouTube. Und vielleicht wollen die halt von beiden weg.
Was meinst du mit, sie bieten QuickTime an?
Nein, ich kriege mit dem H264 Schulung, sodass es in QuickTime geht.
Bring die Sachen nicht durcheinander. Auch Flash ist heutzutage im zunehmenden Maße H264. Wenn du da HD runtergehst, dann ist das alles... Naja, was heißt komisch verpackt? Das ist nicht komisch verpackt, das ist nur, dass dein Flash Plugin das abspielt.
Verstehe.
Wenn du auf Chaos Radio, CDE gehst, da Chaos TV, meine ganzen Videos, da habe ich auch einen Flash Player, weil es deshalb so noch nichts anderes gibt. Aber ich liefere dieselben Dateien aus, die ich auch in den Podcast werfe.
Das kannst du auch, wenn du den Flash Player anschmeißt, und das ist halbwegs hochauflösendes Video, und dann kann man ja in Safari über dieses Aktivitätsfenster die Datei oder zuunterladen, macht man den QuickTime Player auf, fertig ist die Laube, dann hat man da sein H264 Content.
Ja, also, Pfeilformat und Flash, das sind nochmal andere Sachen. Man muss immer den Container, den Player und den Encoder, das muss man irgendwie immer auseinanderhalten. Die Flash-Diskussion dreht sich um den Player. Im Formatbereich ist es einfach auch bei Adobe mittlerweile klar, es ist H264 im MPEG-Fuel-Container, das ist jetzt einfach mal der Standard. Das ist derzeit einfach der Standard und ich sehe auch nicht, wer dem ernsthaft Konkurrenz machen will. Bin allerdings dann so ein bisschen am Schaffen. Google ist zumindest jetzt kein Niemand. Also die haben natürlich, wenn die jetzt irgendwie morgen beschließen, YouTube macht jetzt VP8.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das morgen beschließen werden, aber die, ich lehne mich jetzt mal weit aus dem Fenster und sage, die werden Video-Codecs in JavaScript implementieren.
Nein.
Und kriegen das hin. Oder über ihren nativen Code. Nein, das kannst du vergessen. Nein, das ist ein nativer Code. Doch, das kriegen die hin.
Du brauchst Hardware-Support heutzutage. Du brauchst einfach Hardware-Support. Die einzige Möglichkeit, wie du das machen könntest, ist...
Ja klar, durch deine Grafikkarte.
Okay, gut, das mag sein. Das GPU, das ist... Ja, genau, mit OCL und so weiter. Das ist das Vorstellbare. Aber du brauchst das auch in Hardware. Also wenn du wirklich eine Chance haben willst.
Sie gehen ja immer... Es heißt ja gar nicht, dass... Ich meine, vielleicht wollen sie es ja gar nicht. Wir wollen den nächsten großen Videostandard schaffen. Sondern vielleicht geht es ja einfach nur daran, wenn wir pro Ausstrahlung von H264 über YouTube so und so viel Cent zahlen müssen oder zehntel Cent, dann sparen wir schon mal eine Menge Geld, wenn wir davon 50 Prozent der Clients mit einem anderen Videocodec beliefern können. Vielleicht denken sie einfach so.
Das stimmt. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Bei den Mengen, die sie raushauen, das ist gerade für Google schon echt das Thema. Das kann nämlich sehr gut sein, dass diese Lizenzierungsvorschrift YouTube sogar im Besonderen betrifft. Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie das so zählt, wer dann sozusagen der eigentliche Content-Anbieter ist in dem Moment.
Auf jeden Fall würde es ihr Geschäftsmodell empfindlich stören, wenn sie plötzlich jedem User Geld abverlangen müssten.
Definitiv. Dann hätten sie einfach nochmal für etwas zu zahlen. Wobei sie, ja, sie zahlen wahrscheinlich sowieso schon für Enkoda.
I don't know.
Aber ich denke, dass das die Motivation derzeit ist. Dass es eigentlich um eine politische Keule geht. Genau, vielleicht. Ja, das dazu. Dennis? Da wurde aus der Community gefragt, ob du nicht mal erklären könntest, was du da mit deiner Atom-BSD-Maschine machst.
Ich bin hier für den Atomausstieg.
Du hast doch da irgendwie so ein...
Ich mach mal den schnell...
Ging das an den Router oder Mediplayer? Ich fass nicht mehr ganz genau.
Der Mediplayer war ja immer Max Ecke. Um den Router muss es ja gegangen sein. Also ich mach mal den Schnelldurchflug. Ich hab Anfang 2009, also vor einem Jahr circa, hab ich mir das Atombord gekauft, was damals rauskam. Keine Ahnung, wie es genau hieß. Hat so einen kryptischen Namen. Das hat irgendwie so einen energiesparenden Atomschip. N330 oder so was, irgendwas mit 330. Ist so ein Dual-Core, hat 64-Bit, hat sogar noch Hyper-Swerding. Also das sind vier Cores theoretisch am Ende, aber eigentlich nur zwei richtige. Und wie gesagt, da war noch ein Lüfter irgendwie drauf. Ist so ein kleines Mini-ATX-Motherboard oder so. Und hab ich irgendwie Netze herangeklatscht und zwei Platten mit ZFS-Mirror. Damit war ZFS nochmal erwähnt, aber es geht ja einfach mal nicht ohne. Das steht bei mir auf dem Küchenschrank und macht mein DSL, macht Web Server, macht SVN, macht irgendwie allen möglichen Schnick Schnack. Aber noch mit Lüfter. Und ist deswegen schon leiser als der Desktop. Hab in das neue Ding reingesteckt, hab alle Stecker umgesteckt, eingeschaltet und zack lief genau so wie vorher, nur mit dem neueren Atomchip, der da drauf ist. Und der ist auch wieder 64-bit, Dual-Core plus Hyper-Threading. Und diesmal halt aber ohne Lüfter. Da ist der Chipsatz, den man ja sonst immer extra hat auf so allen möglichen Maserboards und auch bei diesem alten Atom, der ist jetzt in diesen neuen Atomchip integriert. Das heißt, da ist nur noch ein dicker Chip, also die CPU plus gleich Grafik, alles auf einem einzigen Stein und der wird nur noch mit so einem riesen Teil passiv gekühlt. Deswegen irgendwie kein Kühler. Für mich ist der Vorteil, dass es halt leise ist, weil es macht nur noch die beiden Festplattengeräusche, die aber so eine Green Power-Dinge da sind, die hört man fast gar nicht. Und sonst, Maserboard hat halt keine bewegenden Teile mehr. Und du könntest ja auch noch eine SSD ranballern, wenn es ein System ist. Der einzige Unterschied ist jetzt eigentlich, die Gigahertzzahl von diesem neuen Atom, die ist von 1,6 auf 1,66 gestiegen. Also der ist nicht wirklich schneller, der RAM ist jetzt ein bisschen flotter, aber davon merkt man auch nichts. Also aus Geschwindigkeitsgründen müsste man sich die Kiste jetzt eigentlich nicht so holen. Aber mir ist das mit der Lautstärke wichtig, ich will zu Hause, ich will keine, also wenn ich nach Hause komme, dann will ich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes meine Ruhe haben. Und das war mir die 70 Euro wert. Und das war's eigentlich schon.
Und Software?
Software, da läuft halt ein FreeBSD 8.0 stable. Und das Wichtigste an der ganzen Sache, und das ist wirklich der pure Luxus, von dem man immer nie was mitkriegt, ist halt diese neueste Netatalk Installation 205, was ich ja auch schon mal hatte vor mehreren Sendungen, wo das Time Machine automatisch läuft. Und es läuft auch immer noch, nie wieder Ärger. Letztens meint er irgendwas, das Backup wär jetzt voll, er müsste jetzt anfangen alte Backups zu löschen. Hab ich gesagt, der macht alles mir doch wurscht. Weil sonst ist es wahrscheinlich der Hinweis, dass er jetzt mal nachstecken muss, sonst löscht er welche. Also Speicher erweitern. Aber das ist jetzt schon Backup von weiß ich nicht sonst wie viel lange. Also er kann jetzt auch mal ein bisschen löschen von mir aus. Es geht schon okay. Und das funktioniert weiter. Ich komme nach Hause, ich schlage auf, 5 Sekunden später fängt er an, über das Netz Backup zu machen. Das ist total super. Also ich bin total zufrieden.
Ja, ich finde das eigentlich auch ganz interessant. Ich habe ja hier noch diese Time-Capsule, diese neue Version, die macht irgendwie weniger Ärger als die alte. Macht zumindest so den Eindruck. Also bisher habe ich eigentlich gar keinen Ärger. Aber ich mache hier auch alles nur noch mit Ethernet. Nicht mehr mit WLAN.
Ich stecke ja meinen Laptop zu Hause auch immer, wenn ich nach Hause komme, stelle ich auf den Schreibtisch, dann irgendwie Display rein, Ethernet rein, USB rein und dann habe ich auch wieder meinen Display und meine Tastatur und die Maus hat ja sowieso Funk. Und ich nutze den ja nur noch sozusagen. Mein Laptop ist ja zu Hause so eine Art Desktop. Deswegen ist da auch immer Ethernet dran eigentlich. Aber selbst wenn ich im Bett bin und einen Film gucke, sehe ich wie ab und zu kurz das Time-Maschine, also das Time-Maschine, mein Router mountet hier. Das wird ja dann so grünlich hier, das Time-Maschinen-Dings. Wenn er das mountet, dann macht er da irgendwie so ein paar Sekunden was und dann ist das wieder weg. Und du kriegst das nicht mal beim Filmgucken mit. Also das macht einfach rund um die Uhr jede Stunde weg. Das ist der wahre Luxus. Ich muss mich nicht mehr kümmern.
Und das Ganze auch noch auf ZFS.
Und das Ganze auf mein ZFS-Mirror, ja.
Was für ein Porn.
Das Eins hier.
Kann man das bei dir in Auftrag geben?
Ja, irgendwie brauchst du das auch. Das Einzige, was es noch nicht gibt, und das ist ein bisschen blöd, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt erzählen sollte. Mein Rechner hat ja... Ich muss jetzt mal überlegen. Ach fuck it. Mein Rechner hat ja... Also ist alles im Filewall drin.
Ja, das alte Problem.
Genau, ich muss gar nichts zu Ende erzählen.
Doch, erzähl mal zu Ende.
Naja, das Backup ist nicht im Filewall drin.
Wie war es, das Backup ist nicht im Filewall drin?
Na, das liegt halt auf dem Router.
Du hast ein unverschlüsseltes Backup zu Hause rumgehoben.
Ah ne, stimmt ja nicht. Das Filewall wird ja gebacked. Ach ja, ne stimmt, dann ist ja alles...
Nein, nein, aber das Ding ist, wenn du eingeloggt bist, macht er kein Backup von deinem Home.
Mir ging es gerade um so ein Security-Feature.
Es ist nicht so, dass er das dann auspackt und unverschlüsselt ablegt. Sondern es ist so, dass er nur die Filewall-Dateien als solche macht, aber das macht er halt nur dann, wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist. Das heißt, wenn du eingeloggt bist, wenn du es gemountet hast, dein Disk-Image, dein Krypto-Disk-Image, dann kann das nicht sichern. Und das ist eigentlich, ja...
Das ist noch so ein bisschen blöd. Und es muss mich auch ausloggen, dass er dann nochmal irgendwie drei, vier Gigabyte rüberschiebt, weil da hat sich wieder so viel geändert, dass er wieder alles komplett rüberschieben muss. Und das ist schon ein bisschen nervig, aber das geht. Hab ich aber auch schon in der Weile nicht gemacht. Muss ich noch machen. Man ist so selten ausgeloggt. Ich bin eigentlich nie ausgeloggt. Aber ich bin immer, ich bin grundlegend unangenehm. Jedenfalls, was ich dachte letztens, weil ein Kumpel, das irgendwie installiert hat auf seinem Linux, das hat wohl auch geklappt mit Netatalk 205, der meinte auch, dann ist ja da gar nichts verschlüsselt und so weiter. Und das wäre ja aber eigentlich schon ganz wichtig, wenn man noch hier File Vault hatte, da kam ich ein bisschen durcheinander. Aber nee, stimmt gar nicht. Das File Vault, da werden ja wirklich auch die gekrypteten Images werden gebackupt. So gesehen, wenn jemand an meine Daten ran will, dann kommt er da auch nicht ran, weil auch da natürlich weiterhin die verschlüsselten Sachen im Backup rumliegen. Also alles ganz entspannt und es ist gar nicht alles so schlimm.
Aber toll wäre natürlich, wenn man direkt das ZFS...
Krücken könnte und das ist angeblich angekündigt fürs erste Quartal 2010. Und das jetzt schon ganz schön lange, ohne dass sie es weggeändert hätten. Aber die haben schon so oft in der letzten Sekunde das verschobene und das mache ich schon seit anderthalb Jahren. Also da muss man mal gucken.
Wäre das angekündigt Sun oder FreeBSD?
Also da ist ein Typ, der hat es auch schon fertig. Das muss nur jetzt mal irgendwie bei denen reinkommitted werden. Aber dann kommen immer so Zwischen-Features wie D-Duplication und so. Und deswegen muss irgendwie das Krypto geändert werden. Und dann verschieben sie es immer. Und das geht jetzt schon echt anderthalb Jahre so. Aber hier steht jetzt gerade noch aktuell Integration Target Q1CY10. Also Quarter One. Q1CY10. Egal. Jedenfalls erste Quartal 2010.
Sofern CY für 20 steht. Vielleicht ist ja auch erst 21 10 geplant.
Hat jemand von euch Erfahrungen mit ENCFS, also ENCFS? Das ist so ein Fuse-Dateisystem.
Haben wir das Thema jetzt beendet hier irgendwie?
Eigentlich schon.
Also fragst du jetzt was Neues?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was Neues ist. Das ist ein Plug-In-Thema sozusagen. Wegen Verschlüsselung.
Ich muss ja auch mal meine Kapitel-Tasten drücken können. Du kannst ja nicht einfach ein neues Thema aufmachen.
Oh mein Gott!
Ihr kriegt demnächst auch eigene Kapitel-Tasten.
Jeder seine Kapitel. Ich will keine, ich glaub. ENCFS, das ist irgendwie so ein... Ich hab noch nicht so ein Artikel darüber gefunden, wie man das mal eben implementieren kann für sein Mac OS. Das gibt es auf jeden Fall bei Portico. Das kann man sich installieren. Ist eigentlich relativ simpel. Das ist so ein Fuse-Dateilsystem, wo man sich dann quasi... Man legt sich ein Verzeichnis an. Das ist das verschlüsselte Verzeichnis. Und dann legt man sich noch ein zweites Verzeichnis an. Und da mounted man dieses ENCFS rein. Und dann hat man da alle Dateien unverschlüsselt. Klingt eigentlich total dufte. Wie ich so finde.
Ein Pass-Through-Filesystem, was auf Fuse basiert. Das heißt, du hast es inkryptet auf der Platte.
Aber als einzelne Dateien kannst du ein beliebtes Verzeichnis mounten. Was mich so an Fallworten nervt, ich will nicht meine Filme verschlüsselt haben und ich will nicht meine Musik verschlüsselt haben. Sondern ich will vielleicht die Library verschlüsselt haben. Oder ähnliches. Und das könnte man damit alles realisieren. Sie raten sogar explizit davon ab, das gesamte Home-Verzeichnis zu verschlüsseln, weil es wohl nicht alle Features unterstützt, die Mac OS nutzt. Was hier so ACL angeht und sowas. Aber hätte ja sein können, dass jemand damit sich ein bisschen auskennt.
Nö, aber interessanter Hinweis, dass es sowas gibt, müsste man natürlich mal schauen, was da überhaupt, wenn eine Verschlüsselung abgeht, wie stabil das ist.
Und irgendwie gibt es sogar einen Hinweis, wie man es mit seiner... Dafür wäre es natürlich geil, also die haben hier einen Hinweis, wie man es auf seine Dropbox draufkriegt. Quatsch, auf seine iDisk draufkriegt. Und jetzt habe ich schon gesagt, eigentlich wäre es ganz cool, wenn man es für Dropbox machen würde. Wenn man sagt, ich habe hier ein lokales Verzeichnis und wenn ich Dropbox den Typen nicht traue, dass die mit meinen Daten vernünftig umgehen, dann packe ich auf meine Dropbox einfach nur das verschlüsselte Verzeichnis. Das wird dann gesüngt. Das wäre eigentlich eine ganz geile Lösung.
Interessanter Ansatz. Zumal ja auch... Dropbox, genau, das können wir gleich nochmal hier mit reinbringen. Ich hatte ja auch überlegt hier, wie mache ich das so, wenn ich mit One Password, was gleich das nächste Thema ist, aber ich wollte halt meine Keychain auf mehreren Rechnern haben. Und naja, jetzt gibt es ja in One Password die Möglichkeit zum iPhone zu sinken. Ich bin dann so ein bisschen über Twitter mit den Jungs von One Password da so in Diskurs geraten und meinte halt so, naja Leute, wieso baut ihr denn das nicht ein? Na ja, du kannst ja Dropbox nehmen. Aber was ich halt möchte, und das habe ich ihnen dann immerhin in diesem Dialog auch klargemacht, zumindest machten sie auf mich den Eindruck, als hätten sie verstanden, wovon ich rede, dass ich sozusagen nicht bestimmte Daten wie eine Keychain gerne so einem Dienst wie Dropbox anvertrauen möchte.
Auch wenn es verschlüsselt ist?
Auch wenn es verschlüsselt ist, weil was ist eine Keychain? Eine Keychain ist ein Passwort öffnet alles. Das heißt, wenn mir dieses eine Passwort mal abhanden kommt, dann sind gleich alle Sachen weg. Und dazu kommt ja auch noch, okay, dann könnte man sagen, ich kann das Passwort ja ändern, aber nun hat Dropbox natürlich auch noch das Feature, dass es dir alle alten Versionen auch noch aufhebt. Das heißt, wenn du es da auch nur einmal drauf hattest, dann ist ein eingelegtes Passwort potenziell...
Dann hat man auf jeden Fall deine alten Passwörter.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Dropbox die Möglichkeit bietet, dass man diese Versionierung für bestimmte Dateien ausschaltet. Oder man explizit sagen kann, purge mal bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt Sachen. Andererseits habe ich aber auch gemerkt, dass Dropbox ein ganz interessanter Verein ist. Die haben ja auch noch so ein Subsystem auf ihrer Webseite. Das nennt sich Votebox, wo du explizit mehrere Votes abgeben kannst für bestimmte Features. So, und daraus leiten sich jetzt zwei Sachen ab. Das eine war, dass ich gerne wollte, dass One Password einfach auch einen Sync macht über LAN zwischen Macs. Was einfach mal cool wäre, man stellt die Dinge nebeneinander, die laufen irgendwie, die updaten sich. Das ist in gewisser Hinsicht über Dropbox noch eleganter, weil da muss das Programm noch nicht mal laufen. Und du hast immer alles aktuell, das stimmt schon, aber du hast halt diese Probleme. Was auch helfen würde, und was ich dann tatsächlich auch in dieser Votebox, hat mich einer auf Twitter darauf hingewiesen, gefunden habe. Es gibt das sozusagen als Vorschlag, wer Dropbox benutzt und das unterstützen möchte, sollte da vielleicht mal draufklicken, Local Sync einzuführen, ohne dass die Server benutzt werden. Dass du sozusagen von einem Dropbox-Folder sagen kannst, den bitte nicht synchronisieren über den Server. Oder das Einzige, was dir merkt, ist, dass du den nicht synchronisieren sollst.
Ich dachte, das hätten so eine Paid-Version drinne.
Das gibt es nicht, dieses Feature.
Das gibt es nicht. Ich hab neulich gerade vorgestern gehört, dass es eine Paid-Version gibt.
Aber der Local Sync basiert nur darauf, dass du es auch auf dem Server hast. Das heißt, wenn du das jetzt für deine Keychain machen, also wenn du zwei Rechner nebeneinander hast, die beide Dropbox haben, dann sehen die sich zwar über Bonjour. Und wenn du da so eine 4 GB Datei reinlegst, dann wird die dann im Idealfall auch über deinen Laden übertragen und nicht über den Server. Aber es landet trotzdem eine Kopie auf dem Server. Was ich möchte, ist, dass du dem Folder sagst, du bist einfach mal Local Only und du singst nur über ein lokales Netz. Und wenn es kein lokales Netz gibt, dann singt es halt nicht. Selber schuld.
Auch für große Dateien, wo ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die Bandbreite opfern möchte, die ich aber trotzdem gerne in Sync hätte, wär's toll.
Ja, vor allem, was für ein geiles Verkaufsfeature für Dropbox. Derzeit installierst du dir das nur, wenn für dich Synchronisieren über das Netz überhaupt ein Thema ist. Aber Synchronisieren ohne über das Internet zu gehen, ist fast für jeden ein Thema, der zwei Rechner hat. Das ist ja das generelle Problem. Und Apple hat es ja einfach auch im Jahre 2010 keine Antwort. Also wenn du mich fragst, was sie in 10.7 einbauen sollen, was sie wirklich mal lösen müssen, SYNC. Ich will zwei Computer haben und ich will, dass die ordentlich SYNCen. Und zwar ordentlich. Und nicht so diesen bisschen was über Mobile Me, ein bisschen hier, ein bisschen da SYNCen, sondern SYNC einfach.
Und soll ich dir was sagen? Ich würde mir sofort, wenn das geht, einen gleichen Rechner kaufen, weil dann wollte ich meinen Laptop nicht zur Arbeit schleppen. Sondern ich will auf Arbeit einen Rechner haben, der aber bestimmte Sachen auch von meinem Laptop von zu Hause nutzen kann. Bookmarks, Zeugs und so, dass ich da E-Mails lesen kann. Einmal sowas, klar. Aber es gibt tausend andere Schnickschen, also wie auch halt Passwörter. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein Passwort, kommt das jetzt noch ein bisschen deutlicher oder so?
Wir können gleich noch mal drauf eingehen.
Aber all so dieser kleine Fummelkram, weißt du? Klar kann ich mir da Programme erzählen, das ist kein Problem, das mach ich halt alles einmal, das geht. Aber ich will Sachen, die ich abends zuhause mich mit beschäftigt hab, will ich dann nächsten Tag auf Arbeit vielleicht dann auch nutzen können, weil das halt miteinander zu tun hat. Und dann würd ich mir gleich einen Rechner kaufen. Jetzt schlepp ich immer diesen einen Rechner mit rum, weil der ist halt die Zentrale, der hat die Daten und kein anderer Rechner hat die.
Genau das. Genau das ist nämlich das Problem und das widerspricht irgendwie.
Nicht mal auf dem iPhone hab ich hier also die Bookmarks irgendwie, das geht dann nur mit, geht das überhaupt mit Mobile Max, auch die Safari Bookmarks?
Du kannst bestimmte Sachen, also Keychain, Keychain, Adressbuch, Bookmarks und so weiter, also sagen wir mal so die wichtigsten Sachen. Aber es geht halt nicht für irgendwelche Daten. Du kannst halt nicht sagen, dieser Folder bitte auch über Mobile Me sinken. Also diese Dropbox-Funktionalität, als solche haben sie in ihrem ganzen Dienst gar nicht so drin. Und meiner Meinung nach sollten die Jungs sich einfach mal Dropbox kaufen. Das wäre wirklich genau die Erweiterung, die ihr Mobile Me bräuchte.
Oh, ich finde Dropbox unabhängig so toll.
Ich will nicht, dass sie das kaufen. So habe ich es nicht formuliert. Ich wollte ja nicht sagen, sie müssen das auf jeden Fall tun. Ich sage nur, wenn ich Apple wäre, würde ich es machen. Weil das ist einfach die Funktionalität. Und was ich halt auch tun würde, ich würde eben eine lokale Sync-Technologie einführen. Die haben ja im Prinzip auch schon so ein bisschen.
Das muss viel weitergehen.
Und das muss dann halt auch noch diese ganze Back-Up-Frage auch noch mitlösen und so weiter. Das ist im Prinzip eine große Problematik. Aber sie müssen mindestens eine Lösung finden, wie zwei Rechner Ordner syncen können. Das muss einfach gehen. Das ist auch ein gelöstes Problem eigentlich. Da erfordert es einfach nur Fleiß.
Was ich total nervig finde, es sind auch so Sachen wie, ich höre iTunes irgendeinen Podcast an und dann gehe ich auf mein iPhone und muss mir die Stelle wieder von Hand raussuchen. Vielleicht der in der iTunes-Karte nervt.
Was jetzt eigentlich cool wäre, wäre gleich die Marke belegen. Home on iPhone. Da gab es noch mal dieses Home on iPod, oder? Wo sie sich Gedanken gemacht haben und alle dachten, es kommt jetzt, und dann kam da gar nichts von Apple.
Das ist immer wieder gekillt worden im letzten Moment, wenn es das überhaupt jemals gab.
Aber eigentlich wäre es jetzt Zeit für Home on iPhone. Von mir aus, Herr WLAN, Bluetooth, ach du brauchst es wieder nicht, stimmt. Ach, Entschuldigung, ich brauch das.
Ja, du brauchst das, außer dir braucht es keiner.
Außer dir brauchen es alle, du brauchst das nicht.
Wofür braucht man das?
Hab ich doch erklärt gerade.
Dann hab ich es nicht verstanden, wofür?
Weil auf Arbeit ich dann diesen Rechner nicht mitnehmen müsste, sonst könnte ich meine wichtigen Daten irgendwie auf dem iPhone haben.
Dann steckst du dir das iPhone an den anderen Rechner ran, oder steckst es noch nicht mal ran, sondern ein W-Lan.
Problem ist gelöst, externe Festplatte.
Schleppst du jeden Tag mit rum?
So schleppst du als iPhone jeden Tag mit rum.
Ja, tue ich eh. Aber externe Festplatte löst dieses Problem auch nicht so richtig, weil du willst ja auch dein Home haben.
Genau.
Du musst ja dann diese Platte da ranstecken, und dann muss der Rechner sofort wissen, da ist dann dein Home, in dem du dich einloggst, also alles, mit deinen ganzen Preferences, mit deinen ganzen... Ja, World of Sim Links ist dann einfach mal der Big Fail. Eine bessere Methode, alles total in die Scheiße zu fahren, als so anzufangen, gibt es nicht. Das funktioniert nicht. Du musst die Platte ran mounten, und dann muss er sagen, oh, es gibt einen neuen User in diesem System.
Ja, so was ja.
Willst du das erlauben, gib dein Admin-Passwort ein. Zack, bumm, so. Und dann gibt es einen neuen User, der seine Home-Directory ganz woanders hat. So muss das funktionieren.
Das wäre zumindest schon mal ein Feature, dann könnte der Platte noch mal so ein bisschen nachdenken, dann wäre er schon einigermaßen bequemer. Wir sind ja Apple-User, ich will doch nicht basteln, fummeln, machen, tun.
Na gut, war doch eine interessante Diskussion. Dropbox, soll man sich mal angucken. Wenn ihr der Meinung seid, Dropbox sollte Local Sync bekommen, dann geht mal dahin. Ich sehe mal zu, dass dieser Links noch auf die Seite schafft. Ansonsten ist das ja ein ganz cooles Tool, aber ebenso für sensitive Daten schwierig. Vielleicht sagen wir noch ein bisschen was zu One Password sagen. Ich weiß nicht, haben wir da schon mal drüber geredet?
Wir haben schon mal ein bisschen über One Password geredet.
Man kann über One Password nicht genug reden. Das ist wirklich so einer dieser Tools, die einen Unterschied machen auf dieser Plattform.
Das gibt es mittlerweile sogar für Google Chrome in der Alpha-Version.
Ja, die kommen überall rein, die Jungs. Das finde ich echt bemerkenswert. Sie leisten da enorm was, um ihren Browser-Support auch auszudehnen auf jede erdenkliche, nennenswerte Applikation. Und es funktioniert einfach gut. Es gibt nur sehr wenig Buden, die so regelmäßig da weiterentwickeln. Fast jede Woche gibt es da ein Update mit einer riesigen langen Liste, was sie alles gefixt und verbessert haben. Sie sind enorm fleißig. Es ist nicht so ein Tool, was du kaufst, sondern du hast das Gefühl, du bist dann erst mal in den nächsten zwei Jahren wieder alleine gelassen. Da wird richtig fett dran entwickelt. Die haben ja auch jetzt schon für das iPad sich angekündigt, das hatten wir ja vorhin schon erwähnt. Die wollen einfach überall sein. Und du hast ja vorhin die Frage gestellt, denn wozu brauchst du denn das überhaupt? Ich hab doch meine Keychain. Es gibt halt einfach bestimmte Sachen, die kannst du halt einfach mit One Password elegant machen, die gehen mit der Keychain einfach gar nicht. Und das Hauptproblem, was mit der Keychain nicht geht, ist, pro Site zwei oder mehr Accounts haben. Pro Site, für eine Webseite, im Safari.
Also da gab man ja mal diesen Ream, der da kommt, ne?
Ich geh auf twitter.com und er sagt, log dich ein. So, da kann ich dann mit der normalen Keychain, kann ich da halt genau eine holen, und die ist dann auch schon ausgefüllt, oder sie kommen gar nicht. Und ich kann keine andere machen. Wenn ich mit einem anderen Namen einlogge, dann fragt er mich, ob ich die andere ersetzen will. Das will ich aber nicht. Ich habe irgendwie 6 oder 7 oder 8 Twitter-Accounts, und bei anderen Webseiten ist das auch nicht anders. Ich hab mehrere Google-Accounts, ich hab mehrere, was weiß ich. Und das will ich irgendwie verwaltet bekommen. Und das geht einfach mit dieser Keychain nicht. Die Keychain ist gut für jemanden, der eine Identität überall hat, oder, sagen wir mal, verschiedene Identitäten, aber pro Webseite quasi eine.
Das können sie in 7 auch gleich mal fixen.
Und das geht halt einfach mit One Password, geht das ganz wunderbar. Du hast halt überall diesen One Password-Button und der sagt dir dann eben sofort, welche Logins sich anbieten. Und du hast auch noch ganz andere flexible Füllmöglichkeiten. Du kannst zum Beispiel in One Password explizit deine Kreditkarten ablegen. Und dann in einem beliebigen Webform, wo steht bitte Kreditkarten, sagst du einfach, diese Kreditkarte jetzt hier einfüllen, und dann sucht er sich irgendwie die Felder, und das funktioniert auch ganz gut. Oder auch Adresse oder auch andere Sachen. Du kannst dann deine Secure Notes machen.
Und One Password speichert ja am Ende aber auch in der Keychain seine Daten ab.
Genau, er hat eine eigene Keychain. Da haben sie vor kurzem auch mal das Format gewechselt, um besser SYNK-bar zu sein. Agile Keychain nennen sie das. Das ist im Prinzip halt auch mehrere Files. Funktioniert eben wunderbar mit Dropbox zusammen. Das sieht man dann aber auch sehr schön. Du änderst irgendwie so ein Keychain und dann so das Change-Log in Dropbox ist dann irgendwie, ja, durch Bände, wo dann irgendwie so kryptische Dateinamen wurden irgendwie aktualisiert, wo dann so einzelne Files halt für jedes einzelne...
Und wie greift dieses One Password so ins System ein, dass es halt diese Services bietet?
Es klingt sich halt in alle Browser ein und bietet dir dann eben noch mal einen extra Button. Ja, das machen sie auf unterschiedlichste Art und Weise. Es gibt natürlich Browser, das ist einfach. Also Chrome und Firefox bieten ja explizit Plugins.
Für Chrome haben sie eine Zeit lang sogar geschrieben, wir glauben für Chrome können wir es nicht auf die Reihe.
Aber dann kam jetzt Chrome raus mit Extensions-Support, jetzt benutzen sie die Einstiftung.
Ne, ne, auch als es schon Extensions hatte. Offensichtlich unterstützen sie es doch irgendwie.
Wie machen sie das bei Safari, weil ich bin ja Safari-Nutzer.
Ja, bei Safari hatten sie halt Input-Manager lange Zeit und jetzt für die 64-Bit-Version, ich glaube, darum haben wir schon mal gesprochen.
Die sind Symbols und so weiter.
Bitte?
Aber die sind auch nicht mehr erlaubt unter 10, 6 oder?
Mit 64-Bit nicht mehr. Deswegen mussten sie sich für Safari 64-Bit was Neues einfallen lassen. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich das jetzt noch zusammenkriege, wie der Hack lief, aber es geht irgendwie über Scripting Extensions.
Sie bieten irgendwie Erweiterung für Scripting an und haben dadurch einen Hook in das App rein. Also eigentlich eine Sicherheitslücke, wenn man es ganz genau nimmt.
Die dann auch demnächst geschlossen wird, natürlich. Da kennt Apple nix, nehm ich mal an.
Ja, aber Apple werden die nicht mal langsam ihren Browser ja ein bisschen öffnen.
Es ist für mich sehr schwierig. Ich würde sagen, One Password ist mittlerweile schon schwer zu killen. Da würden sie sich schon eine ganze Menge Ärger mit einhandeln, glaube ich.
Haben sie mit Piss Helmet auch so gemacht.
One Password ist noch ein bisschen verbreiter. Ich meine, One Password liefert definitiv einfach eine Antwort auf Fragen, die man sonst schon beim Brausen hat. Also für Power-User.
Dann kann man nur hoffen, dass wenn Apple das nicht macht, dass es auch gleich mit einer neuen Lösung kommt, oder?
Aber ehrlich gesagt, Safari ist doch kein Browser für Power-User. Safari bietet doch nichts über absolute Grundfunktionen hinaus.
Ich bin Power-User, ich mag Safari.
Safari kann auch wirklich nichts.
Ihr seid Power-User? Ich vermisse wenig bei Safari, muss ich sagen.
Flutscht einfach. Die anderen rocken, das geht gar nicht.
Also erstens ist Chrome zum Beispiel einiges schneller als Safari. Safari ist einer der langsamsten Browser auf meinem Rechner.
Du nutzt den Standard Safari oder den WebKit?
Beide.
Und der Chrome schneller als der...
Safari wird unerträglich, sobald man ein paar Tabs offen hat.
Ach so, du bist mit deinen 12.000 Tabs an?
Ich hab einfach... Safari nutze ich ja eigentlich nie, darum habe ich da keine 12.000 Tabs offen. Aber in Firefox habe ich selbstverständlich einen Haufen Tabs offen.
Ach, da links, ja?
Und es gibt einfach so... Für Chrome gibt es mittlerweile ein paar ganz hübsche Erweiterungen, auf die ich echt nicht verzichten möchte. Zum Beispiel eine Liste, der zuletzt... Also, dass ich meine Tabs durchsuchen kann, die ich gerade offen habe. Dass ich Tabs wieder öffnen kann.
Das kann ich aber bei Safari sogar im Betriebssystem, mit Spotlight.
Dass du Tabs durchsuchen kannst?
Naja, wenn ich sie suche, dann durchsucht er unter anderem auch meine ganze Historie und URLs.
Nee, aber welche von diesen Tabs waren jetzt gleich der mit deinem und dem mit deiner Überschrift. Und ich glaube, ich kriege aus Safari nicht mal meine Feeds in Google Reader rein, sondern nur in externe Programme. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Das kann Firefox, das können so alle. Wenn ich jetzt hier oben diesen RSS-Button klicke, der war als allererstes in Safari, fand ich auch ein tolles Feature, dann kann ich damit nur einen externen RSS-Reader aufmachen. Oder eben Safari.
Na, er startet das halt in den Default RSS-Reader. Aber ich vermisse auch die Möglichkeit, ich will manchmal RSS mir einfach im Browser anschauen, ohne dass es der Default ist. Das ist definitiv...
Okay, wir waren bei One Password, aber...
Eigentlich waren wir bei One Password.
Also One Password wird von allen Browsern unterstützt, außer von Apple, die tendenziell dazu neigen.
Ich hab eigentlich alles gesagt zu One Password. Das ist definitiv etwas, wenn man diese Probleme hat, die ich gerade angesprochen habe, dann ist das einfach mal sein Geld wert. Und das ist auch wirklich so ne coole...
Achso, der kostet ja auch was, ne?
Aber es kommt dann auch gleich noch mit einer iPhone-Applikation.
Wenn man's kauft, ist die gleich dabei, oder wie?
Es gibt eine freie Version und eine Pro-Variante, die irgendwie noch ein paar Features mehr hat, die ich mir geholt hab, als die mal kostenlos war. Von daher kann ich gerade jetzt gar nicht sagen, wo der Unterschied ist.
Also für den Rechner erstmal.
Kannst du einfach so erstmal installieren und dann läuft das in der Weile. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was da so ihre Sachen sind.
Kann Safari mittlerweile wieder die Tabs öffnen, die ich beim letzten Mal geöffnet habe?
Ja, in History.
Wie in History? Nein, wenn ich Safari starte, dass es dann einfach meine Tabs wieder öffnet.
Es macht es nicht automatisch, aber es gibt in History ein Kommando, was du aufrufst und dann tut er das. Reopen all Windows from last session heißt das. Ich hab jetzt nur noch einen einzigen Punkt, und dann würde ich auch gerne die Sendung langsam zum Ende führen. Ich weiß nicht, wir waren uns vorhin unsicher, ob ich es schon erwähnt habe, aber so Tools, die ich wieder entdeckt habe, obwohl sie schon lange auf meiner Platte liegen und die immer wieder schön sind, wer mal Lust hat zu installieren, ein kleines Tool, das heißt Observation Post, kommt übrigens von demselben Developer, der auch diesen großartigen FS-Eventer macht, der immer diese ganzen Fallsystem-Events anschaut. Und so ähnlich ist auch Observation Post, das ist, glaub ich, das Tool mit dem ruhigsten oder merkwürdigsten Icon derzeit in der Macintosh-Welt. Auf jeden Fall, was das Ding macht, das beobachtet Events im System. Vor allem Bonjour. Also alles, was irgendwie im Netz sich meldet, nimmt Observation Post zur Kenntnis und kann das dann sozusagen auch über Growl bekannt geben. Was ich auch sehr schön finde, ist, dass er auch alle anderen Events, wie Sleep, wurde eingeleitet oder ein USB-Gerät wurde angesteckt. Also USB, Firewire, Device Events auch nimmt. Sprich, wenn du Observation Post installiert hast und das mit Growl zusammennutzt, dann wann auch immer irgendetwas passiert, um diesen Rechner herum. Warum? Also entweder etwas, das ihnen angeschlossen wird oder von ihm abgezogen wird oder andere Geräte, die irgendwelche Dienste starten oder so. Du siehst es.
Und was passiert dann?
Du startest dein iPhoto mit Sharing an, ich sehe es. Ja, das ist irgendwie und zwar universell für alles Mögliche.
Und was kann ich dann machen?
Du kannst gar nichts machen, das ist eine Observation-Post. Das ist einfach nur ein Tool, was dir einfach nur Vorgänge anzeigt. Das gibt dir einfach reassurance. Was weiß ich, wenn ich hier meinen Mischpult einschalte und das Ding meldet sich über Bonjour mit seinen 16 Kanälen, BUM, die laufen sofort über meinen Bildschirm. Und ich weiß, ah, die Karte ist jetzt gebootet. Ich kriege einfach, deswegen empfehle ich das. Das ist einfach so ein Tool, dass wenn man das laufen lässt, es einem einfach so eine elegante Rückmeldung darüber gibt, welchen Kenntnisstand dein Computer gerade über seine Umgebung hat. Weißt einfach, ob ein Device gefunden wurde, wenn du es angeschlossen hast. Weißt einfach, dass es sich selbst irgendwie ausgeschaltet hat oder sonst irgendwie weg ist. Du merkst, wenn irgendwelche Dienste wegbrechen. Ja, dann merke ich auch, wenn irgendwie eine WLAN-Verbindung stirbt, dass auf einmal bestimmte Dienste einfach wegfallen.
Also jetzt blöde gesagt, ich bemerke Informationen, die ich sowieso habe, kriege ich nochmal präsentiert.
Normalerweise nimmst du solche Sachen ja nicht zur Kenntnis.
Wenn ich eine Festplatte reinstecke, kriege ich das mal gemeint.
Ja, na klar, wenn du selber eine Festplatte einsteckst, aber wenn irgendwie ein USB-Device von sich aus schlafen geht, dann halt nicht. Ich will dir das gar nicht aufzwingen. Ich habe es einfach mal wieder gestartet und festgestellt, dass das einfach sehr gewinnbringend ist. Finde ich einfach cool.
Und man kann also wirklich nur Growl Notifications. Man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, löst doch.
Ja, er zeigt dir halt einfach auch alles noch in einer Liste an, in der das reicht, einfach auf ein Fenster zu schauen. Aber normalerweise habe ich das Ding einfach im Hintergrund, das startet nach dem Login. Und mit Growl holt es einfach die Events nach vorne, weil mich interessiert mehr die Änderung als der Ist-Zustand. Das ist darüber hinaus auch noch ein ganz guter Bonjour-Browser. Also wenn du sozusagen einfach nur mal ein was ist denn sozusagen gerade im Angebot auf meinem Netzwerk haben willst, dann hast du halt eine schöne Liste, wo du nach Namen, Typ, Rechner, IP-Adresse, Port und so weiter unterscheiden kannst und dir dann eben auch dich dann was weiß ich zu bestimmten Diensten auch direkt verbinden kannst. Also einen AFP-Share kannst du da direkt aufrufen und so weiter. Das ist einfach ein schönes Springboard. Und genauso hast du halt eine Übersicht über alles, was USB-mäßig gerade da ist, alles, was Firewire-mäßig gerade da ist, alle Festplatten und so weiter. Ganz einfach. Ja, das war Observation Post. Und meinetwegen können wir jetzt langsam aufhören, weil ich wollte auch um halb definitiv fertig sein.
Ich muss um halb fertig sein.
Du musst um halb fertig sein. Und Dennis hat keine Widerrede. Du hast fertig. Tja, dann bleibt uns nur noch zu winken, oder? Wir können ja nochmal den Chat fragen, aber da kommen bestimmt jetzt nur absurde Vorschläge, worüber wir uns noch unterhalten können, die uns hier stundenlang an den Sitz fesseln. Aber heute machen wir einfach mal eine ganz knappe Sendung. Das waren, na, elegante, nicht ganz drei Stunden. Das ist ja geradezu eine Discount-Sendung hier. Okay, haben wir's? Seid mal ein bisschen euphorischer.
Super, 42 abgeschlossen.
Wir haben nicht mal eine 42-Referenz eingebaut.
Wir haben nicht einen dummen Witz gemacht. Doch, wir haben eine Menge dumme Witze gemacht. Keine, der sich auf 42 bezieht. Was soll man dazu auch sagen? Aber vielleicht bietet ja der Inhalt dieser Sendung Antworten.
Erleuchtung.
Gefeiert wird, wenn wir was Rundes haben. Genau, das ist ein sehr schöner Satz. Mach's gut und danke für den Fisch.